hey there future ethical hackers welcome
to this exciting journey into the world
of cyber security and ethical hacking if
you have ever wondered how to become a
digital superhero defending the digital
realm from cyber threats you are in the
right place in today's video we are
diving deep into the world of ethical
hacking and uncovering the secrets
behind this thrilling and rewarding
field whether you are a tech Enthusiast
looking to expand your knowledge or
someone and considering a career change
this video is your gateway to
understanding what ethical hacking is
all about we will explore the Core
Concepts the skills you will need and
the incredible opportunities that await
you in the cyber security industry trust
me this is the ultimate PowerUp for your
Tech Career and if you're an aspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certification from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply lar postgraduate program in
cyber security from m MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and require just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% of average
and no prior experience and one plusus
year of work experience is preferred for
more details use the link mentioned in
the description box below and if you're
dreaming of earning prestigious cyber
security certificates like cissp C or
com Security Plus this program is your
ticket to success we offer a cyber
security expert m program that is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and it requires no
programming experience or work history
our program not only equips you with the
essential cyber security skills but also
prepares you for the industry's most
esteemed certifications making you an
expert in the field let's hear from our
Learners about the personal experience
and the success story after graduating
from the simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security from Mi
University hello everyone and welcome
back to Simply learns YouTube channel
ethical hacking is the practice of using
using hacking techniques to test the
security of a computer system Network or
application with the goal of identifying
vulnerabilities and improving the
overall security of the system with
increasing Reliance on digital systems
in various Industries there has been a
growing demand for skilled ethical
hackers ethical hacking offers a
lucrative career option with a high
salary and the potential to work as a
freelancer or as a part of a team with
that being said it is sufficiently
evident that cyber security and ethical
hacking are amazing career option
options for every individual out there
so without any further delay let's jump
onto our topic right away if you want to
enter the field of cyber security and
grab a high-paying job then simply
learns postgraduate programm in cyber
security in collaboration with the MIT
University is surely the right option
for you this postgraduate program in
cyber security will help you learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you'll get foundational to
advanc skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
this program for admission to this
postgraduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
grades and candidates with one plus year
of work experience are preferred so join
now the course link is mentioned in the
description box below let us start by
understanding what ethical hacking is
ethical hacking often referred to as
Whitehead hacking involves using your
cyber security skills to protect systems
and and networks in 2024 this field is
more critical than ever due to the
increasing number of cyber attacks your
role as an ethical hacker is to find
vulnerabilities before malicious hackers
do and secure digital environments
before we begin let's talk about the
prerequisites to excel in ethical
hacking you should have a strong
foundation in computer science or it
familiarity with programming languages
like python C++ and Java will be
beneficial as they are commonly used in
cyber security tasks it's essential to
follow a structured learning path so
start by gaining a deep understanding of
networking you need to comprehend how
data flows through networks the various
protocols in use and security mechanisms
that protect them next delve into the
world of operating systems understanding
the intricacies of most popular
operating systems like Windows Linux and
Mac OS is crucial for ethical hackers
you'll often encounter vulnerabilities
at this level certifications play a
pivotal role in your ethical hacking
career consider pursuing certifications
like certified ethical hacker certified
information system Security
Professionals coma Security Plus and
certified information security manager
cism these certifications are recognized
by industry professionals and can open
up doors to many exciting job
opportunities learning by doing is
crucial in ethical hacking engage in
Hands-On experiences such as capture the
flat competitions participating in bug
bounties and setting up your own home
lab these activities will sharpen your
practical skills and deepen your
understanding of vulnerabilities and
exploits cyber security is a rapidly
evolving field stay updated with the
latest threats tools and techniques by
following cyber security news attending
conferences and engaging with online
communities the ability to adapt to New
Challenges is a Hallmark of a successful
ethical hacker ethical hacking is all
about doing good all us are there to the
law obtain proper permission when
testing systems and respect privacy and
confidentiality ethical behavior is not
just a requirement it's a Cornerstone of
this profession as you progress build a
strong portfolio document your
achievements successful hacks and
projects a well-maintained portfolio
will not only showcase your skill but
also make you stand out to potential
employers building strong networking
skills is essential attend cyber
security conferences and join
professional associations like Issa
information system security Association
or s AA Information Systems audit and
Control Association networking not only
enhances your knowledge but also opens
doors to job opportunities and
collaborations coding and scripting are
your secret weapons Master scripting
languages like Python and Powershell
these skills are invaluable when
automating security tasks creating
custom tools and analyzing malwares
incident response is a critical aspect
of cyber security understand how to
detect respond to and recover from
security in incidents familiarize
yourself with incident response
Frameworks like nist and ISO
271 this expertise is highly sought
after by organizations looking to
Bluster their cyber defenses don't
underestimate the importance of soft
skills effective communication teamwork
and problem solving abilities will set
you apart in the workplace ethical
hackers often collaborate with cross
functional teams and strong
interpersonal skills are essential for
success in this ever evolving field
continuous learning is your best friend
stay curious and explore some emerging
Technologies like Ai iot and Quantum
Computing as they bring new security
challenges learning about these
Technologies and their Associated
security risks will make you an
invaluable asset to any
organization join online communities and
forums where ethical hackers share
knowledge and experiences platforms like
GitHub and stack Overflow can be
invaluable for collaboration and
learning engaging with the community
allows you to tap into the collective
wisdom of experienced hackers looking
ahead consider specializations with
ethical hacking such as mobile security
I security or Cloud security these
niches offer exciting career paths and
opportunities to become an expert in a
specific area of cyber security ethical
hacking is a field that will continue to
grow in coming years and you can upskill
yourself to start your professional
career in this amazing field meet an she
often shops from www. shoppingcart
she has her information like email ID
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hasslefree shopping
experience the required information is
stored in a server one day an received
an email which stated her eligibility
for a special discount voucher from
shopping cart.com in order to receive
the coupon code she was asked to fill in
her shopping cart.com account
credentials this didn't seem fishy to
her at the time as she thought it was
just an account verification step little
did she realize the danger she would be
facing she was knocked off her feet when
a substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake an's shopping cart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a Cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
an prevented this attack indeed she
could have with the help of cyber
security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks you are
prone to so let's take a look at the
various cyber attacks that an could have
been exposed to
one of the most common types of cyber
attacks is a malware attack like Trojan
Adwear and spyware to name a few had
Anne downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a fishing attack the type of
Cyber attack which Anne experienced here
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate Source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
login
credentials another type of attack is
the man in the- Middle attack here the
hacker gains access to the information
path between Ann's device and the
website server the Hacker's computer
takes over Ann's IP address by doing so
the communication line between an and
the website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Ann's
password could have been cracked by
using either common passwords or trying
all possible alphabetical combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks an
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices first she installed a firewall
as the name suggests it is a virtual
wall between an's computer and the
internet firewalls filter the incoming
and outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly and
implemented honeypots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called honeypots are used to
attract attackers these systems are made
to look vulnerable in order to deceive
attackers and this in turn defends the
real system in addition to these she
also decided to use unique alpha numeric
passwords antivirus software and started
avoiding s from unknown senders that was
Ann's story cyber attacks are not just
confined to individuals but also to
public and private organizations the
cyber attacks carried out in such places
are more deadly and they result in
colossal losses motives of such attacks
are many starting from tampering with
crucial data to monetary gains let's
have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information companies also witnessed the
denial of service attack where networks
are flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
workor there are multiple job roles in
the field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to exp
Network's vulnerabilities just like how
a hacker would do but only to identify
those vulnerabilities and resolve them
for protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more act a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization so here's a question for
you identify the type of Cyber attack
where the hacker system takes over the
client's IP address a DDOS attack B man
in the middle attack c fishing attack d
password attack give it a thought and
leave your answer in the comment section
below three lucky winners will receive
Amazon gift vouchers with the increase
in the production of global Digital Data
it is anticipated that cyber attacks
will quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need cyber
security professionals who can prevent
these attacks a career in the field of
cyber security is lucrative and a very
smart decision for professionals now we
humans are highly techsavvy in today's
times with the extensive use of the
internet and modern Technologies there
is a massive challenge in protecting all
our Digital Data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly one to cry
ransomware attack the attack happened in
May 2017 in Asia and then it spread
across the world within a day more than
230,000 computers were infected across
150 countries the oneac cry crypto worm
encrypted the data and lock the users
out of their systems for decryption of
the data the users were asked for a
ransom of $300 to $600 in Bitcoin the
users who used the unsupported version
of Microsoft Windows and those who
hadn't installed the security update of
April 2017 were targeted in this attack
the one a cry attack took a toll on
every sector top tier organizations like
Itachi Nissan and FedEx had to put their
businesses on hold as their systems were
affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives let's have a look
at three different types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have
wheh hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers in addition to these
hackers we also have the gray hat
hackers as the name suggests the color
gray is a blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act but
they do this without seeking the owner's
approval sometimes gry hat hackers also
ask for money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lumpsum ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infostructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
Jon was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad John in this scenario
exposed the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how Jon our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step John takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack back this step is
called reconnaissance he uses tools like
inmap and hping for this purpose John
then tries to spot the vulnerabilities
if any in the Target system using tools
like inmap and nexos this is the
scanning phase now that he has located
the vulnerabilities he then tries to
exploit them this step is known as
gaining access after Jon makes his way
through the organization's networks he
tries to maintain his access for future
attacks by installing back doors in the
Target system the metas sploit tool
helps him with this this phase is called
maintaining access Jon is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase Jon documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think JN is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at it ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pentest
plus and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert Masters
program that will equip you with all the
skills required by a cyber security
expert you could have a look at it by
clicking the link in the description so
here's a question for you in which phase
of ethical hacking will you install back
doors in the Target system a scan
B maintaining access C clearing tracks D
reconnaissance give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comments
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers the endless
growth of Technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes cyber crimes are estimated
to cost $6 trillion in 2021 hence to
tackle these cyber crimes organizations
are continuously on the look lookout for
cyber Security Professionals the average
annual salary of a certified ethical
hacker is $91,000 in the US and
approximately rupe's 7 lakhs in India so
what are you waiting for get certified
and become an ethical hacker like John
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world data is the new goal imagine
how much data is generated by just your
smartphone every single day be the
pictures you click or the messages you
send nearly 41 million messages are sent
worldwide via WhatsApp every single
minute so safeguarding your personal
data against hackers has now become a
top priority did you know that India
leads the world when it comes to ethical
hackers with 23% of the worldwide
hacking population from India the top
ethical hackers earn more than twice of
what software engineers in India do but
what makes ethical hacking such a
demanding industry ethical hacking is
the process of taking security measures
to safeguard data and networks from
malicious cyber attacks the hackers use
use every tool at their disposal to try
and breach the security barrier and find
any potential vulnerabilities the
ethical in ethical hacking denotes the
lack of malicious intent since these
sessions are often permitted by the
system owner or the network that is
being hacked into to fix any compromised
entry points before black hat hackers
discover and exploit them so what is a
black hat hacker you may ask a hacker
who exploits security vulnerabilities
from monetary gains like stealing or
destroying private data altering
disrupting or shutting down websites and
networks is known as a blackhe hat
hacker on the other end of the spectrum
we have white hat hackers who help
people secure the networks by stress
testing the platform against the most
dangerous of cyber attacks that is with
their consent of course but the most
neutral of the bunch are grayhead
hackers who may not ask for consent
before snooping on a foreign system but
they do inform the owner if they find
any vulnerabilities sometimes in
exchange for a small fee the security
breaches have become less and less
prevalent thanks to rigorous ethical
hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness Ness programs the ability to
fix critical security issues before
blackout hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation are looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28% by 2026 with salaries going
as high as
$225,000 perom so that's ethical hacking
wrapped up in 2 minutes to catch more
bite size and detail videos on different
Technologies subscribe to Simply learn
and stay updated in today's digital age
where cyber threats Loom large
understanding ethical hacking is crucial
by dwelling into the world of ethical
hacking you gain a deep comprehension of
hacker techniques and vulnerabilities
which will enable you to strengthen your
security measures with a demand for
cyber Security Professionals soaring
learning ethical hacking opens doors to
wide range of exciting career
opportunities moreover it empowers you
to protect your personal data and
privacy while staying one step ahead of
evolving cyber threats by embracing
ethical hacking responsibility you
contribute to a safer digital
environment enhanced problem solving
skills and Foster continuous growth get
ready to embark on an exciting journey
into the realm of ethical hacking and
discover its immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who's interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a shot
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security from Schwan's College of
computing in collaboration with EC
Council the link in the description box
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
take action up skill and get ahead but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like subscribe button
and click on the Bell to never miss an
update from Simply learn without further
Ado let's get started with understanding
why you must learn ethical hacking there
are a wide variety of reasons of why to
learn ethical hacking let's discuss the
important ones firstly cyber security
awareness next strengthen security
measures career opportun unities
protection of personal data awareness of
cyber threats ethical use of skills
problem solving and continuous learning
now that we have few important reasons
let's discuss each one of these
important reasons in a bit more detail
firstly cyber security awareness
learning about ethical hacking provides
you with a deep understanding of the
techniques and methods used by hackers
this knowledge helps you identify
vulnerabilities in your computer systems
networks and applications enabling you
to better protect them the next one is
strengthening security measures by
learning ethical hacking you can
actively contribute to improving the
security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cyber saing
and there is a high demand for skill
profession
by acquiring knowledge of ethical
hacking you can open up various career
opportunities in Industries such as it
security Consulting penetration testing
and incidence response next ahead we
have protection of personal data
understanding ethical hacking techniques
empowers you to safeguard your personal
data with privacy you can Implement
security measures to protect your
devices online accounts and sensitive
information from potential
attacks awar Ness of cyber threats is
the next one on the list the digital
landscape is constantly evolving and new
threats emerge regularly learning
ethical hacking helps you stay up to dat
with the latest cyber threats attack
vectors and vulnerabilities enabling you
to proactive your measures to mitigate
the risks followed by that we have
ethical use of skills ethical hacking
emphasizes the responsible and legal use
of hacking techniques by learning
ethical hacking you gain the knowledge
of the ethical guidelines and legal
boundaries associated with cyber
security this ensures that your skills
are utilized for positive purposes
protecting individuals and organizations
from malicious attacks next on the list
is problem solving skills ethical
hacking requires critical thinking
problem solving and analytical skills
through learning ethical hacking you
develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains next and the list is continuous
learning and growth cyber security is a
dynamic field that demands continuous
learning to keep up with evolving cyber
threats learning ethical hacking ensures
that you remain engaged on ongoing
education and skill development
fostering personal and professional
growth now let's get into the important
aspect of today's tutorial that is
salary details for for a certified
ethical hacker in the United States of
America the salary of an ethical hacker
can be based on various factors such as
experience skill level location industry
and the organization they work for
generally ethical hackers in USA tend to
earn higher salaries than other
countries due to the demand for cyber
Security Professionals entry-level
positions may start around $60 to
$80,000 perom while experienced
profession professionals with Advanced
certifications and specialized skills
can earn salaries exceeding
$150,000 per anom the salary of ethical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors such as experience skill set
location and organization they work for
on an average a beginner level ethical
hacker in enging from three lakhs to 6
lakhs perom as they gain more experience
and
expertise their salary can increase
significantly EXP ethical hackers with
several years of experience and advanced
certifications can earn salaries ranging
from 8 to 20 lakhs or more annually now
proceeding with the companies hiring
ethical hackers several companies hire
ethical hackers to enhance their cyber
security defenses and protect their
systems here are some prominent
companies known for hiring ethical
hackers Google Facebook Microsoft Apple
Amazon IBM Cisco Intel Deo and and evi
are the most prominent ones the topics
that we are going to discuss in this
video are what exactly hacking is the
types of hackers the classifications
what is ethical hacking the skills that
are required of an ethical hacker the
process that is utilized by ethical
hackers in their daily activities and
then we lastly we're going to discuss
cryptography so let's talk about hacking
and what exactly hacking is hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems now here there are some key
words that we need to understand first
and foremost exploit when you're
exploiting weaknesses weaknesses are
technically called vulnerabilities which
are basically design flaws
misconfiguration errors usage of default
usernames and passwords which have not
been modified so any misconfiguration or
anything that has been left behind by a
Security administrator that can be
misused which means exploited by a
hacker to gain unauthorized access so
the next term is unauthorized access
something that you're not allowed to do
and when you say a hacker is a person
who tries to hack it's basically a
person with malicious intent trying to
gain access to a system or a resource
that they are not authorized to access
in the first place how do they do it
they find a varability that is a
weakness or a flaw and then they misuse
it to gain access to that particular
Network so here in the diagram you can
see that a sender on the left hand side
is trying to send some data to the
receiver on the right hand side the
hacker would try to gain unauthorized
access to the transmission that is being
sent and would try to capture the data
packets and read the secrets within
let's look at a business case scenario
into hacking now there is an
organization uh everybody is going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there's an attack that has
happened and based on that attack they
have realize that the data has now been
compromised and the records have been
modified uh by the hacker which means
that the data is no longer trustworthy
and thus cannot be used by the business
for any legal transactions so then the
hacker gives a call to to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding a ransom for the
data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lumpsum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues at as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and uh make these ransomware demands so
the company then uh wants to figure out
even if having a security system in
place how was the hacker able to hack
their systems thus one of the employees
comes up with a brilliant idea of
identifying vulnerabilities in the
network uh to proactively search for any
flaws that have been left behind uh so
that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them thus they figure
out that they want to hire a ethical
hacker who would help them identify the
security posture of the organization
identify the weaknesses vulnerabilities
and flaws and help them remedy those
flaws so that in future scenarios these
scenarios will not happen so before we
go into an ethical hacker let's
understand what are the types of hackers
so what are the types of hackers hacker
is a technically skilled person uh who
is very Adept with computers they have
good programming skills they understand
how operating system works they
understand how networks work they
understand how to identify flaws and V
abilities within all of these aspects
and then they understand and know how to
misuse these flaws to get a outcome
which would be detrimental to the health
of the organization so there's six type
of hackers that have been identified
black hat hackers white hat hackers gray
hat script kitties nation sponsored
hackers and a activist so blackhe hat
hackers are Bas basically uh the
malicious hackers who have malicious
intent and have criminalistic Tendencies
they want to harm the organization by
hacking into their infrastructure by
destroying their infrastructure by
destroying their data so that uh they
can gain from it from a monetary
perspective uh these guys are also known
as crackers the main aspect of these uh
people are that they have malicious
intent they try to do unauthorized
activities and they try it for personal
gain another important aspect to
remember is that a black hat hacker will
always try to hide their identity uh
they will spoof their online digital
identity by masking it by spoofing their
IP addresses Mac addresses and try to
remain anonymous on the network a
whiteed hacker on the other hand is also
an ethical hacker or a security analyst
who's an individual who will do exactly
the same thing that a blackhead hacker
would do minus the malicious intent plus
the intent of helping the organization
identifying the flaws and remedying them
so that nobody else can misuse those
vulnerabilities so they are authorized
to act on the company's behalf they're
authorized to do that activity which
would help the company identify those
flaws and thus help the company mitigate
those flaws improving on their security
posture so these uh these kind of
Security Experts or ethical hackers
would help organizations defend
themselves against unauthorized attacks
gray hat hackers is a blend of both
white hat and blackhead hackers so here
they can work defensively and
offensively both they can accept
contracts from organizations to increase
their security posture at the same time
they can also get themselves involved in
malicious activities towards other
organizations to personally gain or
benefit from them by doing unauthorized
activity script kites are people uh who
are technically not much aware about
what hacking is uh they rely on existing
tools that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools uh if the hack works it
works otherwise it doesn't so these
people are basically who are noobs or
newbies who are trying to learn hacking
or uh just uh people who with malicious
intent who just want to have some fun or
trying to impress people around then we
have the nation or the state sponsored
hackers as the name suggest these
hackers are sponsored by their
government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers uh enrolled
in their p on um on their organizations
to spy on their enemies to spy on
various countries and try to figure out
uh the aspirations of those countries so
this is basically a spying activity
where you're technically trying to get
access to other Count's resources and
then try to spy on them to figure out
what their activities have been or what
their future plans have been and then we
have the activists who is an individual
who has a political agenda to promote
and they promote it by doing hacking so
uh these guys what is the difference
between a blackhe hat hacker and a
activist the blackhe Hat ha hacker may
try to hide their identity a activist
will claim responsibility of what they
have done so for them it's a political
agenda political cause and they will try
to hack various organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website and posting the
messages that they want to promote on
these websites so what exactly is
ethical hacking then we have discussed
the types of hackers we have identified
a malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent uh of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization which
would give them a definite scope of what
they're allowed to do and what they are
not allowed to do and the ethical
hackers would function within those
Scopes would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
have the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again ethical hacker is a
highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how opera
in systems work they can troubleshoot
they're technically very Adept at
Computing they understand the
architecture they understand how various
components in a computer work they can
troubleshoot those components and they
can basically be uh very good with
programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of
their companies with the permission of
cons concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire an ethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls what idss ipss inen detection
or intren prevention systems antiviruses
are already in place and then they will
ask the ethical hacker to figure out a
way to bypass these mechanisms and see
if they can still hack the organization
what is the need of an ethical hacker
the need of an ethical hacker is
proactive security the ethical hacker
would identify all the existing flaws in
an organization and try to resolve those
flaws to help secure or the organization
from blackhe hat hackers so ethical
hackers would prevent Hackers from
cracking into an organization's Network
by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
Network vulnerabilities or application
Level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then Tred to figure out a way of
plugging them or uh resolving them so
that they cannot be misused by other
hackers they would also analyze and
enhance an organization security
policies now what are policies policies
are basically documents that have been
created by an organization of rules that
all the employees need to follow to
ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are uh they contain the alphabet through
Zed uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9
as numerics and special characters and
they're randomized so that the password
becomes more more stronger to prevent
from Brute Force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if Brute Force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they would ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are as
secured as the policies want them to be
if there are any gaps in the the
policies or the implementation of the
policy it is the ethical hacker
responsibility to identify those gaps
and warn the organization about it
similarly they would also try to protect
any personal information any data that
is owned by the organization that is
critical for the functioning of the
organization and they'll try to protect
it by from falling into the Hacker's
hands now what are the skills that are
required of an ethical hacker these are
the following skills so first and
foremost they should have good knowledge
with operating systems such as Windows
Linux unit and Mac now when we say
knowledge about operating systems it's
not only about how to use those
operating systems but how to
troubleshoot those operating systems how
these operating systems work how these
operating systems need to be configured
how can they be secured for example
securing an operating system is not only
installing a firewall and an antivirus
but you need to configure permissions on
an operating system of what users are
allowed to do and what users are not
allowed to do for example limiting the
installation of applications how are we
going to do that we need to go into the
system Center the security Center of
Windows and we need to configure
security parameters over there of what
are acceptable softwares and what are
not same with Linux and uh Mac softwares
operating systems so we need to know how
we can secure these operating systems
similarly all of these would have
desktop versions and server versions of
operating systems as a ethical hacker we
need to know the desktop and server
versions both how to configure them and
how to provide services within the
organization on these servers so that
they can be consumed in a secure manner
by all the employees at the same time
they should also be knowledgeable of
programming languages or scripting
languages such as PHP python Ruby HTML
for programming if you will because web
servers come into the picture so again
they should not be great developers
where they can create huge applications
but they should be able to develop
scripts understand those scripts analyze
those scripts and figure out what the
output should be of those scripts to
achieve the hacking goals that they have
have set out for an ethical hacker
should have a very good understanding
about networking no matter whether
you're in application security you're in
network security or you're in host based
security since a computer will always be
connected to a network either a local
area network like a lan or the internet
we should know how networking works we
should know the seven layers of the OSI
model we should know which protocols
work on those seven layers we should
identify the tcpip model and how OSI
model can be mapped to the tcpip model
we should understand how TCP and UDP
work how how each and every protocol is
crafted how they are supposed to behave
for us to analyze and understand any
network based attacks we should be very
good in security measures so we should
know where those vulnerabilities would
lie what are the latest exploits
available in the market and we should be
able to identify them we should be able
to know the techniques and the tools of
how to deal with security how to analyze
security and then how to implement
security to enhance it as well along
with that it is it is important that a
security analyst or ethical hacker is
aware of the local security laws and
standards why is that because an
organization cannot do any illegal
activity whatever responses that they
have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hacker
should be aware of what security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming uh it's good to
have a certification in PHP Pearl python
Ruby and so on so forth why because most
of the organizations when they hire
ethical hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that that they can be
sure or they can be assured that the
person that they're hiring has the
required skill set so let's talk about a
few of the tools that a ethical hacker
would utilize uh in their testing
scenarios to be honest there are
hundreds of tools out there what you see
on the screen are just a few examples of
them uh nessus is a vulnerability
scanner what is a vulnerability scanner
it is an automated tool that is designed
to identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within uh operating systems within
Networks so they come with their rade
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
they scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like uh actic or Arachne that
would help you scan applications and
identify flaws within those applications
as well now all of these are automated
tools the essense of ethical hacker is
when these tools churn out the reports
the ethical haer hacker can understand
these reports analyze them identify the
flaws and then craft their own exploits
or use existing exploits in a particular
manner so that they can get access or
they can bypass the access security
controls mechanisms that are already in
place how can they do that with the tool
called Metasploit you see that Big M
there on the right hand side that M logo
is for a tool called Metasploit which is
a penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is is that
tool that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metas sploit to validate those
flaws and to verify that those flaws
actually exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas helps us do that wi sh Shar
would be used in the background while
you're doing both the activities using
nessus or Metasploit to keep a track of
what packets are being sent and by
received on the network which will help
us analyze those packets so whenever I
run an SS scanner I would run a y shock
in the background it will capture the
data packets and I can go through those
data packets and analyze that data
packets to identify what nesses is
actually trying to do similarly when I
try to attack a machine using exploit on
metas sploit I will keep on wire shock
running in in the background to capture
the data packets that have been sent and
the responses that I've received from
the victim so that I can also go through
those packets and analyze the responses
and analyze the attack whether it was
successful to what extent was it
successful and basically will also give
me a validation a proof of the activity
that has happened nmap is another
automated tool that allows me to scan
for open ports and protocols so why
would I use nmap because Pro ports and
protocols become an entry point for a
hacker to gain access to devices for
example when we connect to a web server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https so if I'm
connecting to a web server using https
it is safe to assume that Port 443 on
the web server is open to accept those
connections similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there's a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the SQL map
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that that we would follow so there are
six steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
recognizance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hacker
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a
windows-based server and I use a
particular tool to attack it but it
actually turns out to be a Linux Bas
server my attacks are going to be
unsuccessful so I need to focus my
attack based on what is there at the
other end so in my information gathering
phase I want to identify all of that
information once I have that information
done I'm going to scan those servers
using tools like nmap that we just
talked about and we're going to try to
see the open ports open services and
protocols that are running on that
server that can give me possible entry
points within the network or within the
device or within the operating system at
the same time along with the scanning
with nmap I would run a vulnerability
scanner the nessus vulnerability scanner
we talked about or actic for
applications and then I will try to
identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either cracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting
availability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist existing or
somebody changed the password that may I
may have cracked does I no longer have
access so so what do I do to maintain my
access I install Trojans or backd door
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where I maintain my access I have hacked
them now I want to maintain my access so
I install a software which would give me
a back door entry to that device no
matter what once I've done this I want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that I've been doing for example
installing a a Trojan a Trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victim's machine so I want to hide
that if I have accessed data stores if I
have modified data I want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
or even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where I will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any viser of whether they have
been compromised or who compromise their
system and if I am successful at all of
these stages or what to whatever extent
the success that have achieved in any of
these stages I would then create a
report based on that and I would report
to the management about the activities
that we have been able to do and
whatever we have been able to achieve
out of those activities for example we
identified 10 different flaws there were
20 different attacks that we wanted to
do what attack did we do what was the
outcome of that attack what was the
intended or or the expected output of
that attack I'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like nmap HP to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again n map next POS these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metas tool
that we talked about in the previous
slides in the maintaining access you're
going to install back doors you can use
metas at the same time uh you can craft
your own scripts to create a Trojan and
install it on the victim's machine once
you have achieved that clearing tracks
is where you're going to clear all
evidences of your activity so that you
do not get caught or the victim doesn't
even realize that they have been hacked
and once you done all of this we are
going to create reports that are going
to be submitted to the management to
help them understand the current
security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred millionar through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go
onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your price
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gila most of
humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social injuring attack where
you can plead with them saying if I do
not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attack to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack we
it would be easily be able to uh gather
the information that you have set for
your security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
cool that you attended you probably have
that listed on your LinkedIn profile
where person can just go in there and
see your academic qualifications and
identify the school that you were in
right similarly it might also be a
question what was your mother's maiden
name that's a very good attack and
that's uh I mean if a person can
interact with you let's say they're
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it fishing as
discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing uh comes into
mind uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever Falls
victim will fall victim so if I just
throw around a few USBS in the parking
lot obviously with Trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in the those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed uh we just talked about the uh
Nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
pray upon the person's greed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to uh get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we just
making it unreadable or non-readable by
using a particular key or a particular
algorithm and then we're going to send
the key to the end user the end user
using the uh same key would then decrypt
that data if anybody compromises that
data while it is being sent over the
network since it is encrypted they would
not be able to read it so the encryption
algorithm would be something like this
now if you see uh the computer word once
made into unreadable format would look
like e q o r XV GT for a end user it
wouldn't make any sense but the person
who has a key to unscramble that would
be able to convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
Cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus three so C plus three
alphabets that becomes e o becomes q m
becomes o so the key that is utilized to
scramble the dat data is the character
that you are at the third character from
there would be the corresponding key so
the encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and you can now figure out what that e
correspondent to by going back three
characters in the alphabet most of the
times a certified ethical hacker must
decrypt a message without knowing the
secret key so let's say a ransomware has
affected your organization or has
affected a device and you want to figure
out uh or you want to decrypt that data
now as a ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a crypt analysis Crypt analysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so Crypt analysis
can be done using various formats the
first one is a Brute Force attack second
is a dictionary attack third one is a
rainbow table attack a Brute Force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is
100% successful but may take a lot of
time a dictionary attack is where you
have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tant out to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the cipher
text is compared with another Cipher
text you find out similarities and then
you try to work a reverse engineer your
way accordingly so let's have a quick
demo on cryptography before we end this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on a website called
spam mic.com which will help us scramble
the message that we created into a
completely uh a format which would be
unrelated to the topic at hand so if I
say I want to encode a message turn a
short message into spam so what this
does is want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so whoever
is reading that spam mail would never
get an idea of the embedded message
within it so if I want to type in a
message here hi this is a secret message
the password is ASD at1 1234 and I want
to send this out to people or to one of
my colleagues but I want to send it out
in a secret manner so that others are
not aware of this so when I press on
encode what the algorithm would do is it
will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this a secret
message the password is atate 1 234 or
ASD at 1 234 gets converted into this
now if you read it dear e-commmerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
I've already said so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I'm going to click on decode
when I click on decode I'm going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I code this you will see
that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt
website where let's say we use text
encryption and I want to encrypt the
same message this is a secret message
the password is ASD at1 234 and then I
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
I use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say AES which is the
strongest Cipher right now and I say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically uh if I
don't have the password over here if I
decrypt it you would see that the error
has occurred now if I type in the
password over here and then decrypt it
it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at theate 1 234 so if I want to keep
my data secure from hackers I want to
scramble it in such a way that they
would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker
and before we begin if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply lar postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schmith College of computing the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered hello everyone and welcome to
this video on the hackers road map at
the simply land YouTube channel as vast
as the field of cyber security is
there's often an overflow of information
about it at the same time for people who
wish to know more about how to venture
into the cyber security or ethical
hacking space it is very important for
them to know what's the career
progression what are the skills needed
and how a person with no or bare minimum
knowledge can take the first step in
this amazing career well this video is
for all those individuals who wish to
pursue a career in the field of cyber
security and ethical hacking whether you
are an entry-level professional a
college graduate or an experienced
professional looking to understand how a
career in the field of cyber security
progresses and what additional skills
and responsibilities would you need as
you grow in the field then you are at
the right place so let's get started
with our topic the hackers road map and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
El sits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
that and try giving a sh to Simply Lun
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT shman College of
Engineering the course link is mentioned
in the description box that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered and if these are
the types of videos you would like to
watch then hit the Subscribe button like
and press on the Bell icon to never miss
on further content so stay tuned with us
until the end of this video and don't
forget to register your opinion in the
comment section below and now we will
start with what is ethical hacking and
how is it different from hacking so in
the world of cyber security hacking can
be broadly categorized into two types
ethical hacking and unethical hacking
ethical hacking involves using the same
tools and techniques as malicious
hackers to identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these expert known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather on theft and on the
other hand we have unethical hacking
that refers to unauthorized access to
digital devices or networks with
malicious intent performed by black hat
hackers and additionally there are gray
hat hackers who possess knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes working as Security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in black hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as whad
hackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real world attacks and help
organization strengthen their security
measures the role of an ethical hacker
involves several key phases and we'll
see those roles and key phases so they
are responsible for reconnaissance
scanning can and maintain access clear
their tracks document their findings and
compile detailed reports
so firstly they conduct thoro Recon
gathering information about the target
system or organization this includes
understanding the organization structure
Network infrastructure and potential
weak points and through scanning they
identify the easiest and quickest
methods to gain access to the network
and gather further information and once
access is gained ethical hackers
maintain it allowing them to exercise
their privileges and control the
connected systems this step helps them
identify any potential security flows
and weaknesses within the network they
also work to clear their tracks covering
their footsteps to evade detection and
ensuring the security personel cannot
Trace their activities and throughout
the entire process ethical hackers
document their findings compile detailed
reports on the vulnerabilities
discovered and provide recommendations
to address and mitigate the identified
security issues their vulnerability goal
is to help organization strengthen their
defenses prevent data breaches and
protect sensitive information from
falling into the wrong hands ethical
hacking is a crucial aspect of cyber
security as it allows organizations to
stay one step ahead of cyber threats by
leveraging the skills of ethical hackers
businesses can proactively identify and
address vulnerabilities ensuring the
overall security and integrity of their
digital infrastructure so now we'll see
the skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker
so now we'll see the skills so the first
skill is knowledge of computer networks
then it's the programming languages then
the knowledge of web applications
databases ethical hacking tools and
knowledge of common attack vectors and
techniques then what certificates that
are required for an ethical hacker now
we'll start with knowledge of computer
networks understanding computer networks
is fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages Proficiency in
programming languages is essential for
Effective ethical hacking languages like
python Java C++ and scripting languages
such as Pearl or ruik are widely used in
this field programming skills enable you
to write custom scripts and tools
automate task and explore
vulnerabilities and the next we have is
web applications in today's digital
landscape web applications are often the
target of attacks therefore a solid
understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dbms such as
MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL Server
learn about database security including
access control encryption and
vulnerability assessment then we should
focus on the skill to have a knowledge
on ethical hacking tools so to perform
ethical hacking task efficiently you
should be familiar with various hacking
tools these include Network scanners
example nmap vulnerability scanners
example nessus password crackers Joon
the riper packet snipers W shck and
exploitation Frameworks metas sploit
mastering these tools with enhance your
Effectiveness as an ethical hacker then
you should have knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques that is
understanding common attack vectors and
techniques is vital for an ethical
hacker this includes knowledge of
different types of malware social
engineering Network attacks that is DDOS
and web application vulnerabilities
example crite scripting staying up to
date with the latest threats and attack
methodologies is crucial for Effective
defense the next is certificates so
obtaining relevant certifications
demonstrates your expertise and
commitment to the field certificates
like certified ethical hacker CH
offensive security certificate
professional oscp or coma Security Plus
are highly regarded within the industry
they validate your skills and can boost
your credibility when seeking ethical
hacking opportunities the CH
certification is a multiple choice exam
that evaluates your understanding of the
penetration testing structure and the
tools that are utilized inside it it
gives job Seekers the information
security field a head start by ensuring
that the certificate holder understands
the fundamentals such as information
gathering attacking computers or servers
Wireless attacks and social engineering
so the objective CHS inform the public
that credentialed individuals meet or
exceed the minimum standards
second establish and govern minimum
standards of credit
enity third professional information
security specialist in ethical hacking
so now we'll have an exam overview so
the exam name is EC Council certified
ethical hacker and the exam duration is
240 minutes and you will get questions
that is 125 questions you will get in
the exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is
70% and and to register for the exam you
should go to peon view or ECC Exam
Center and eligibility criteria for CHS
there are two ways to satisfy the
eligibility criteria that is attend
official CH training and this can be in
any format example instructor Le
training computer Based training or live
online training as long as the program
is approved by EC Council and attempt
without official training in order to be
considered for the EC council
certification exam with without
attending official training you must
have two or more years of documented
information security experience remit a
non-refundable eligibility application
fee of $100 submit completed CH exam
eligibility form including verification
from an employer upon approval EC
Council will email you a voucher number
to register for the CH exam so this was
all about the CH exam and now we'll move
to the steps to become ethical hacker so
ethical hacking is an exciting and
rapidly growing field that requires a
combination of technical skills
knowledge and a strong sense of Ethics
by following these steps you can begin
your journey towards becoming an ethical
hacker and contribute to enhancing cyber
security so step one that is knowledge
of computer systems and networks step
two you should have Proficiency in
programming languages step three
networking and security Concepts you
should have a knowledge of it third
knowledge of web application and
database fifth understanding of
operating systems step six family arity
with ethical hacking tools step seven
problem solving and analytical thinking
step eight knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques step nine
certifications so now we'll elaborate
all the steps one by one so we'll start
with knowledge of computer systems and
networks so to become an ethical hacker
it is crucial to have a deep
understanding of computer systems and
networks this involves familiarizing
yourself with the inner workings of
computer system Network protocols
operating systems and how different
components interact within a network
environment by gaining this knowledge
you will be better equipped to identify
vulnerabilities and assess potential
security risk and the next is
Proficiency in programming languages so
programming languages are an essential
tool for ethical hackers by gaining
Proficiency in programming languages
such as python C++ Java JavaScript SQL
per and Ruby you will be able to develop
your own scripts automate task and
create exploit codes the programming
languages provide the foundation for
writing secure and efficient code as
well as manipulating and analyzing data
the next step is networking and security
Concepts to effectively assess and
secure networks it is important to have
a solid understanding of networking and
security concept this includes
familiarizing yourself with topics such
as Network protocols network security
principles encryption techniques and
firewall configurations understanding
how data is transmitted secured and
protected in a network and envirment
will enable you to identify potential
vulnerabilities and Implement
appropriate security measures step four
knowledge of web application and
database knowledge so in today's
interconnected World web applications
and databases are common targets for
hackers therefore it is crucial to
develop a strong understanding of web
application architectures web protocols
and database systems be special
attention to Common vulnerability
specific to web applications such as SQL
injection cross side script in xss and
cross site request forgery csrf by
gaining expertise in these areas you
will be able to effectively assess the
security of web applications and
databases and provide appropriate
recommendations for securing them and
the next step is understanding of
operating systems so operating systems
form the backbone of computer systems
and are often targeted by hackers it is
important to gain a comprehensive
understanding of different operating
systems such as Windows Linux or Mac EOS
this includes understanding system
configurations file permissions user
management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and secure
operating systems effectively step six
familiarity with ethical hacking tools
ethical hackers rely on a variety of
tools to assess and secure systems and
networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
met spotti wi shock and map BB suit Kali
Linux canvas SQL ninja and B these tools
provide functionalities for
vulnerability scanning Network sniffing
exploit development and penetration
testing understanding how to use these
tools effectively will enhance your
capabilities as an ethical hacker now
we'll see the step seven that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and device
effective strategies to mitigate risk it
is essential to stay updated with the
latest security Trends and Technologies
to enhance your problem solving skills
and the step eight is knowledge of
common attack vectors and techniques so
to defend against potential threats you
must familiarize yourself with common
hacking techniques and attack vectors
used by malicious hackers this includes
social engineering fishing attacks
password cracking network based attacks
and more understanding how these attacks
work and the methodologies used will
enable you to proactively identify and
prevent potential security breaches and
now the step nine that is certifications
while certifications are not mandatory
to start a career in ethical hacking
they can provide a structured learning
path and validate your skills and
knowledge consider pursuing
certification such as certified ethical
he
CH offensive security certified
professional OSP certified information
system security professional cissp
certified penetration Testing Engineer
cpte and certified security analyst ecsa
these certifications demonstrate your
expertise and dedication to the field
enhancing your credibility as an ethical
hacker now we'll see the job roles in
ethical hacking field so starting with
like there are several job roles in
ethical hacking such as here's an
elaboration on each job role in ethical
hacking and we'll see some of the major
ethical hacker job roles so starting
with ethical hacker so an ethical hacker
is a skilled professional who legally
attempts to penetrate computer system
and networks to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses they use their knowledge
to strengthen the security
infrastructure and protect against cyber
threats and the next is network security
engineer network security Engineers
specialize in securing and maintaining
computer networks within an organization
they Implement and manage security
measures such as firewalls intrusion
detection systems and virtual private
networks that is VPN to protect
sensitive data then we have cyber
security analyst so cyber security
analyst Monitor and analyze systems for
potential security breaches or incidents
they investigate threats develop
security protocols and Implement
measures to protect against attacks the
next is penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackers
simulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities in computer systems
networks and applications they conduct
Thor assessments and provide
recommendations for improving security
the next is information security manager
information security managers are
responsible for overseeing an
organization's overall security strategy
and ensuring the protection of sensitive
data they develop and Implement security
policies manage security teams and
handle incident response and the next is
cyber security engineer so cyber
security Engineers design and Implement
security systems including firewalls
encryption protocols and intrusion
detection systems they also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions the assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial did you
know that in August this year Google
openly admitted that some of its Gmail
accounts were hacked by an Iranian group
fortunately the event was isolated and
was taken care of but rarely are
security breaches this easy to stop with
more and more data moving to the cloud
the prospects of hacks like these have
grown in the past decade exponentially
consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical I hackers in the IT industry so
today's video is all about how you can
learn the ins and outs of hacking and
cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simply learn before we get started
ensure you're subscribed to the channel
so you always stay updated with the
latest Technologies and Trends let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people people in the hacking field
wearing the white hat so what exactly is
the responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for a
cooperation as independent Freelancers
inh house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well all of these careers need
knowledge of current attack
methodologies and tools albe the
in-house expert may need to be
knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like Ki Linux and
parad security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stressfree the better vers
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux and a lot of backend code
are written in C having a strong hand
over this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or JavaScript which will help you
d set giant pieces of Servo code like
butter remaining Anonymous is vital in
the hacking sphere since giving a
malicious actor news of your existence
on a Target Network can cause him then
to flee or attack your device instead
the usage of Mac address randomizers and
proxy chains is highly beneficial and
recommended when monitoring networks for
criminal activity and speaking of
proxies ethical hackers must understand
networking fundamentals and exactly how
they are established learning about
various networks and protocols might
help you exploit flaws
an ethical hacker with an extensive
understanding of networking tools such
as wire shock nmap and others can
overcome field incidents relatively
unscathed the fifth skill in our list is
traversing the darkware using the famous
T browser most of the internet is hidden
behind the tour networks and getting a
closer look at the people who often are
at the Forefront of the hacking industry
in the dark web directly can help you
familiarize yourself with a certain
domain Secrets while keeping you updated
with the latest happenings in the cyber
crime World A major advantage that can
tip the scales in the Famer of an
ethical hacker is the knowledge of
cryptography or encryption encryption is
used in various elements of information
security including authentication data
Integrity anonymity and others passwords
and other sensitive information are
always encrypted on our Network a hacker
must understand how to recognize and
break these encryption standards
exploring vulnerabilities make you a
better ethical hacker simply keeps you
aware of the security measures that are
kept in place as industry standards
while handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security Beach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord Reddit Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum now that we understand some
basic skills ethical hackers need to
excel in this domain let us look at the
road map one can follow to get started
many ethical hackers begin their careers
by studying computer science you can
also acquire an A+ certification from
comp tiia by appearing for and passing
two additional tests these test assess
an individuals understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain a
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and strives for foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you'll obtain expertise
in network security and your goal should
be offered as a position as a network
engineer as a network engineer you will
build and plan networks rather than
simply maintain them your focus should
now be on the SEC security part of your
journey to becoming an ethical hacker
this is the time to focus on earning a
security certifications such as Security
Plus or CSP the US Department of Defense
has approved the Security Plus
accredition which covers testing on
critical areas such as Access Control
identity authentication and cryptography
the cissp certification is a worldwide
recognized security accredition that
validates the expertise of risk
management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information secur division an
information security analyst studies
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain hands-on
experience with some of the most
essential tools of the trade getting the
certified ethical hacker or the C
certification should be your top
priority the training will teach you all
you must understand to become a
productive and ethical hacker you will
be engaged in a Hands-On environment
where you will be guided through
breaking into a network and finding any
security flaws after obtaining this
certification you can begin marketing
yourself as a professional ethical
hacker we have already covered some
skills one needs to learn when stting
their Journey however an ethical hacker
has certain roles and responsibilities
that must be carried out meticulously
the first of which is threat modeling
threat modeling is optimizing network
security by identifying vulnerabilities
and determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident Je izing the
organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security these regular exercises assess
Security's Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threats they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect collect
data detect vulnerabilities and
correlate risks to create clear and
unambiguous professional reports these
evaluations are frequently used to
justify finalizing security asset
expenditures the market for trained
ethical hackers has never been this
expensive according to various surveys
the job outlet for ethical hackers and
information security analyst is supposed
to grow by 33% between 2020 and 2030
companies like IBM Google and Microsoft
are always on the lookout for trained
cyber security Personnel in this climate
of data breaches and security
vulnerabilities we hope this video has
cleared some doubts regarding where to
start and what to learn during this
journey when it comes to web app hacking
It generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators pose these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous Mal to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or produce the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the hypex
transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like GS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing back window
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies n
map nmap which stands for network mapper
is a free and open Source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service up time it is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system before running
the necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and thus breach the
device nmap users Raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in Ed and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works F against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and and
ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systematic
vulnerabilities on both networks and
servers because it's an open source
framework it can be easily customized
and used with most operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use rade or custom code
and introduce it into Network to probe
for weak spots as another flavor of
threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions once a particular
vulnerability is identified and the
necessary exploit is fed into the system
there are a host of options for the
hacker depending on the vulnerability
hackers can even run root commands from
the terminal allowing complete control
over the activities of the compromise
system as well as has all the personal
data stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the actic
framework AC unetic is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security testing tool
that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space
actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross- site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other outof band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as well it
also lets you scan complex multi-level
forms and even password protected areas
of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as s scanners sast tools only
work during development and only for
specific languages and have a history of
reporting lot of false positives whereas
Dynamic testing tools also known as D
have the ability to streamline testing
from development to deployment with
minimal
issues next on our list we have air
geden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
Linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday Wi-Fi router
and its counterparts along with being
able to launch denial of service attacks
on compromised networks this
multi-purpose wi-fi hacking tool has
very rich features which support
multiple methods for wi-fi hacking
including WPS hacking modes WP attacks
handshake captures evil twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open-source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and add-ons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 GHz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an
open-source password security auditing
and the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
100 of hash and Cipher types including
for user passwords of operating systems
web apps database servers encrypted keys
and document files some of the key
features of the tool include offering
multiple modes to speed up the password
cracking automatically deselecting the
hashing algorithm used by the passwords
and the ease of running and
configurating the tool to make it
password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users and allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just missed
the cut net sparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any F so you can focus on fixing
the reported
vulnerabilities the bup suit
professional is one of the most popular
penetration testing and vulnerability
finder tools and it's used for checking
web application security the term B as
it is commonly known as a proxy based
tool which is used to evaluate the
security of web based applic
and to do Hands-On testing moving away
from websites and applications yasak is
a free and open-source packet analyzer
which was launched in 2006 it is used
for Network troubleshooting analysis
software and Communications protocol
development and education it captures
Network traffic on the local network and
stores data for offline analysis Yar
captures Network traffic from ethernet
Bluetooth wireless networks and frame
relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
gamechanging since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors another advantage of hiring
ethical hackers is the ability to
preemptively fix possible weak points in
a company's Network infrastructure as
seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of this is not to
imply that such security audits are only
beneficial to the organization paying
for it when coming across companies that
provide certain Services a reliable
thirdparty security audit goes a long
way in instilling trust and confidence
over their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical bence of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount in this we are going
to discuss ethical hacking and
penetration testing so we're going to
talk about the concepts about what
constitutes an ethical hack and what is
a penetration test we're going to talk
about the different types of penetration
test and how they can be done we're
going to talk about an operating system
called Khali Linux and we're going to
talk about its usage and its importance
in cyber security we'll also be
discussing the different phases of
penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases uh to
gain their objectives we'll also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration tests we'll be discussing
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the Ki Linux
space and then we'll be looking at a
couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's start with with
what is ethical hacking now plainly
defined ethical hacking is locating
weaknesses or vulnerabilities of
computers and information systems using
the intent and actions of a malicious
hacker the major difference is here that
we are hired to discover those
weaknesses in a legal and ethical manner
that means first and foremost our intent
should not be malicious we do not wish
any harm to the organization and
whatever we discover is reported back
and not misused once we report back we
would also be trying to help them out to
mitigate or remove those weaknesses or
vulnerabilities to enhance the company
security posture so essentially we would
have the same training or the same
knowledge as that of a malicious hacker
except that the intent is going to be
different the intent is going to help
the organization achieve security to
protect themselves against malicious
hackers and the second most important
thing about ethical hacking is that we
are authorized to do that activity I
cannot in good faith hack somebody and
then tell them you know what I just I
just wanted to help you out and uh here
are your vulnerabilities and uh this is
the way you can prevent them I first
need the authorization from the other
party and only then can I perform an
ethical hack so in this example hacker
attacks an individual with malicious
intent and makes misuse of whatever
information they have gotten they steal
the data they maybe fry the operating
system Hardware destroy it and thus uh
they leave the victim without uh a
device with authorization an ethical
hacker can also attack the same
individual minus the destruction of
course and the intent is good so they
willingly finding out the
vulnerabilities and helping the victim
plug them out so that they wouldn't be a
victim of a malicious attack now here
the first thing is authorization from
the victim and the second thing is the
good intent where we do not misuse those
vulnerabilities and we report them back
to the victim or to the client and help
them uh patch those vulnerabilities
that's the main difference between a
white hat and a black hat so Security
Experts are normally termed as white hat
hackers malicious hackers are termed as
black hats now the responsibilities of
ethical hacker are multifold first and
foremost you have to create scripts test
for vulnerabilities first have to
identify those in the first place so
there's vulnerability assessment
identifying those vulnerabilities and
then you're going to test them to see
the validity and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as a ethical
hacker run a vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the repercussions if those
vulnerabilities actually get exploited
so I'm trying to find out in risk
assessment that if the client gets
hacked with the vulnerabilities
identified what is the loss they would
be facing once they get hacked and the
loss could not only be loss of data it
could be Financial losses it could be
loss of reputation penalties they have
to pay to the client for breaches or
penalties that they may have to pay for
pay the governments in case of breaches
that happened that uh couldn't be
controlled another the responsibility of
the ethical hacker is to set up policies
in such a way that it becomes difficult
for hackers to get access to devices or
to protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so uh we got
a lot of employees in an organization we
need to train the staff of what is
allowed and what is not allowed how to
keep themselves secure so that they
don't get compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password you're not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there is a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be uh a buffer over overrun flaw
or it could be a simple password
cracking attempt your idea is to create
those tools create those attacks and try
to penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denal of service
attack or any other V abilities that you
have identified uh during the volum scan
so what is Ki Linux and why is it used K
Linux is an operating system oftenly
used by hackers and ethical hackers both
because of the tool sets that the
operating system contains it is oper
Operating System created by
professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a deian based operating
system with Advanced penetration testing
and security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus odd tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in the
middle attacks sniffing password
cracking uh any of these attacks would
be possible with all the tools available
you just need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said hundred of hundreds of tools
uh that is used for various information
security tasks like uh computer
forensics rever reverse engineering
information finding even uh getting
access to different machines and then uh
creating viruses worms Trojans anything
that you will 600 plus tools in the Kali
Linux operating system there are
periodic updates that are given out to
the operating system as well it is open
source that means it is free to utilize
you can even have the source code you
can modify it if you want to there's
customizations available for all the
tools you you can download third party
tools and install them if you want
there's a white support for wireless uh
network cards multiple languages are
being supported at the time at the same
time as well and you can create a lot of
attacking uh scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on Ki Linux so this
all all in all helps you create a very
robust system where you can create your
own attacks and then launch them against
unsuspecting victims now that is illegal
so as far ethical hacking is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools should be
utilized you're going to get the
appropriate permissions and only then
are you going to attempt those attacks
let's talk about the phases of
penetration testing now there are five
different phases the first one is the
recognizance phase also known as the
information gathering phase this is the
most important phase for any hacker this
is where the hacker or the ethical
hacker if you will will gather as much
information about the targets victim or
V vers the V the victim right so once
you have that information you would then
be able to identify what tool sets to
include and how to attack the victim for
example you want to find out the IP
addresses the domains subdomains the
network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future
email addresses telephone numbers
anything and everything that will help
you validate and give you information
about the target is something that you
want to do in the recognizance phase at
this point in time we are not going to
question whether whatever information we
are getting is useful or not only time
will tell depending on the various
attacks that we will be building up
later on this becomes your Baseline this
becomes your database with all the
information about the victim so that you
can come back from later stages back to
the recognizance phase to to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can find tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within the network once you've
identified the live machines you'll scan
them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we going to identify
vulnerabilities Within These processes
and Within These open ports so in the
scanning phase uh why do we need to find
live machines because we want to find
out the machines that have booted up
have an operating system and are running
on the network if an machine is not
available on the network or is in a
shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be our
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there are any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we go onto the gaining access phase
where we are going to attack and try to
get access to our victims machines could
be a social engineering attack based on
the information gathering we have done
in the technical assessment and scanning
phase if you have identified a
vulnerability you're going to identify a
relevant exploit and then use that
exploit to try to gain access or we
might just craft a Trojan and try to uh
execute that trojen on the victim's
machine to uh check if we can get access
through that particular manner once we
have the access could be even a simple
password cracking attack which we have
been able to accomplish and we have
cracked the password of the person and
now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be used
useless if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if we
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install uh root kits key loggers
sniffers and things like that where we
could get a back door entry to the
victim's machine if we have already been
successfully installed a Trojan we would
want to add the Trojan to the startup
menu so that every time the operating
system starts the Trojan gets
automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a Trojan a Trojan
being an application would create
directories and files a virus would be
destructive in nature if you're
executing a script it will leave some
logs behind if we even login through the
cracked password that we have it will
create a login entry at for that
particular time time stamp along with
the IP address that we utilized in the
covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs are been
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking inions
exploits for the Vol lities if any
maintain that access by installing
further software which will allow you to
get back door access to that particular
system and then try to cover your tracks
by deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a backd door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in an ethical Hacker's
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we have got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the blackbox test the
blackbox test is where no information is
given to the ethical hacker about the it
infrastructure so they have no idea what
it is they start right from the first
phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employees
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges uh like an administrator but
is just a a regular employee does that
means that they got limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the it
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the it infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can can compromise any stuff any of the
data so the three attacks would be the
first one blackbox where we are
simulating a external threat a hacker
sitting outside the organization trying
to gain access the gray box is an
Insider threat where there's a regular
employee who is trying to get access to
infrastructure that they are not
authorized for and then the third audit
is a white box audit where there's an
administrator who has all the leverage
all the access and the visibility within
the infrastructure and then they're
trying to misuse their access to see
what else they can get from whatever
access has been authorized to them now
let's look at the areas of penetration
testing where all could we do a
penetration test does compromising the
security of the application or of the
server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in a network all of these are
devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been been correctly
secured they would leave some V
Liberties behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by uh getting access to the
network in the first place then we have
the web applications web applications
are nothing but softwares that are
developed over or deployed over a web
server and are made available over the
intranet or the internet for example uh
web sites that we visit or web
applications like Facebook if you will
right so if these applications have
vulnerabilities within them we then try
to attack the web based applications and
thus try to bypass authentication or get
access to database or try to leak
information through those applications
if not then we try to attack the client
side now web application is at the
server level and is hosted by the
deployer so that's at the server site
the client side is where we as users are
using a computer with a browser and
trying to interact to the web
application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client side vulnerability
and then exploiting it to either either
hack the client or then piggyback on the
client's connection and try to get
access to the server so either you could
attack the network the web application
or the client side itself or you could
attack wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphon
phones tablets faets all of those
connected to them if you're able to
access any of these devices through the
wireless it would help you gain access
to other devices on the wireless as well
and then social engineering so this is
where you're trying to attack humans
you're tracking an employee of a
corporation to reveal some confidential
information knowingly or unknowingly by
tricking them with the fake mails or
fake websites or malicious emails that
you have sent to them uh which they have
failed to recognize as as malicious and
they click on it thus getting victimized
social engineering attacks are always uh
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage of if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million
dollars and we have been identified as
the person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails uh we
have also received emails of lottery
tickets that we have won over a period
of time without even having bought a
lottery ticket so if you haven't bought
one what did you win but we don't ask
these questions we just get excited
about the amount of money that we have
won and then we try to bet on our luck
and try to see if that uh email is going
to fructify or is it just another the
scam so social engineering attacks are
dime a dozen these days and we need to
be very careful on what we trust on the
internet let's look at the penetration
testing tools there are hundreds and
thousands of tools out there most of
these have been concised and collected
together and hosted on a operating
system known as KH Linux that we have
talked about earlier now the predecessor
to KH Linux was backtrack backtrack is
no longer continued it has been
discontinued and Kali Linux has taken uh
the place of backtrack within which are
all the tools that you see on your
screen metas sploit is one of the most
favorite penetration testing tools of
hackers and ethical hackers uh there are
a lot of inbuilt exploits over there and
we'll be doing a demo at the end of the
session on this nmap is the information
gathering tool which will scan for live
devices scan for open ports protocols
and services beef would be an
application testing tool that would help
us uh find exploits within applications
nessus vulnerability scanner is a
network and a host based scanner that
would help you identify vulnerabilities
within such hosts wi shock is a network
sniffer which allows you to capture
Network packets and and analyze them to
see if there are there is any
information worth capturing within those
packets SQL map is a automated tool used
for SQL injection attacks so you don't
even have to craft your queries for SQL
injection it will be done by the SQL map
tool you just need to identify whatever
is possible through the queries that
this SQL is going to create and then
based on the activity that you've
identified you just need to redefine
your search parameters to get access to
the database we'll be doing a demo on
SQL map or SQL map as well and then
there is John the Ripper John the Ripper
is a tool that is used for password
cracking so dictionary attacks Brute
Force attacks are done using John the
Ripper what is a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack is an attack where we
create list of all probable passwords
store them in a txt file and run that
list against the password tool to see if
any of those passwords are going to
match a Brute Force attack is trying the
same attack but with every permutation
and combination of the alphabet that we
have and we're going to try to figure
out uh if we are able to crack the
password at all so these are just some
of the tools for every tool there are
another supporting 100 tools or more
than that uh like for NS vulnerability
scanner you'll have quis vulnerability
scanner you have uh GFI lanard and there
are other lots of other softwares out
there but these are some of the most
commonly utilized tools let's look at
the metas attack Metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on metas sploit we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer run runs until
execution and then exits uses brute
force and exits when an error occurs in
a passive exploit these exploits wait
for incoming request and exploit them as
soon as they connect they can also be
used in conjunction with emails and web
browsers so in passive exploits we
create a payload we uh like a reverse
connection payload we send it to the
victim once the victim installs that
software the machine will then initiate
a connection to us our machine will be
in a listen mode and then we will once
the software is executed at the end we
would then try to connect and exploit
that particular vulnerability this is
the uh practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see uh what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had uh talked about in the ethical
hacking and penetration testing module
we are going to look at three different
demos the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we're going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password cracking attack
on Windows 7 and the third one is a
interpreter based or a metas sploid
based shellshock attack on a Linux based
web server so let's get cracking I've
powered on this virtual machine uh which
is the ovas broken web application it is
a tool that is provided for people who
want to enhance their skills and they
can practice uh how to do these attacks
in a legal manner so we are going to go
to this site I'm just going to open up
my browser the IP address is
7132 and that's the ovas broken web
application that we want to utilize
we're going to head off to mutil Day 2
and we are going to look at a SQL
injection attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try our luck
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a SQL
database and uh we can uh try to attack
it and see uh if we can bypass the
authentication now uh what we want to do
is is we want to create a SQL based
malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's a error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried uh
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
give us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how the syntax works here we
just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R 1 equal one space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we we now have
admin access to this application now
here the SQL queries need to be crafted
in such a perspective that they're going
to work so there would be a lot of
exercise in identifying what the
database is there's a Microsoft database
and Oracle database and so on so forth
and then you have to choose those proper
commands but identifying that would come
in the training right now we're just
looking at at a demo this is how a SQL
injection attack works now let me log
out here similarly now we are in a login
page the same query worked wonders where
it allowed us to bypass authentication
so it also depends on what kind of a
page I am and what query would be
accepted at this point in time so here
application understanding would also
come into the picture where uh which
function we calling upon when we
connected to a particular page now this
is a user lookup function right so again
here we try the same method test test
that's not going to work authentication
error by user on password and if you
type in the same query over here single
quote or and give it a condition single
quote or one equals one space hyphen
hyen space now here it is not going to
log Us in because this is not a login
page this is a user lookup form so here
it would instead give us a dump of all
the databases that it has so you can see
all the usernames and passwords coming
in that are stored in the user lookup
field so this is where the understanding
comes in of which query to create at
what page we are depending upon the
function that is being called right so
that's the SQL uh injection attack that
we wanted to look at let's move on to
password cracking now this is a Windows
7 machine that we have I'm just going to
do a very basic password tracking
example we're just going to log in now
here the assumption is that we are able
to log in we have access to a computer
and we want to check out other users who
are using this computer and see if we
can find out their passwords so that uh
we can log in as a different user steal
data if required and we wouldn't be to
blame if there are any logs that are
created so here we've got a tool called
can enable that is installed right here
now I'm already an administrator on this
machine I'm checking out other
administrators who share the same
privileges or any other user who may be
on this system whose password I can
crack and thus I would be able to get
access through their account and then do
any malicious activity right so this
allows me to go into a cracker tool and
it allows me to enumerate this machine
and identify all the users and passwords
that are there in this particular
machine right so I'm just going to click
on the plus sign and I'm going to import
hashes from a local system so where are
these files stored where does Windows
store its passwords in what format are
they stored and what this tool does to
retrieve those that's something that we
all need to know as a ethical hacker
right so import the hashes from the
local system click on next it's going to
enumerate that file and it is going to
give you a list of all the users that
are there so you can see the users are
hacker admin test the one that we logged
in as and then there's a user called
virus as well and you can see that this
is is the hash value of the password
that is being utilized now there's a
particular format uh for a hash value
for Windows and how it stores but once
we have these hash values let's say if I
want to crack this password there are
various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an ntlm
hash attack and here we're going to use
a predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and lowercase a through Zed uppercase a
through Zed numeric 0 through 9 and all
the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that we
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a Brute Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100% successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords uh there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux server that I have that I'm going
to power on I'm going to use a k Linux
machine to hack that device and I'm
going to just power off my Windows 7
machine give it a minute till it boots
up now this is also a demo machine that
we have which has its own preconfigured
vulnerabilities so here we've got
something from the pentesters lab uh and
has a shell shock vulnerability imp
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability uh affects Linux Mac and
Unix based operating systems for a
particular version of The Bash shell
bash is the bone again shell which is
the command line interface in these
operating systems so what we're trying
to do here is we're going to use the K
Linux machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we're going to use metas sploit to
attack this machine now the first and
foremost thing is we want to identify
the IP address we have no idea what the
IP address is we are in the same subnet
so we are assuming that we're able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called Zen map I'm going to to open
up a command line interface find out
what my IP address is and my IP address
is this with a subnet mask of 2555 255
255.0.0.0
assuming that 133 is the machine that we
want to look at and let's then try to
see if we can scan that machine 133 and
we're going to do an intense scan to
find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pintest machine that
we were looking for you can see of the
start Port 22 and Port 80 and somewhere
here it's going to give us the ports
that are open and the details about
those ports and somewhere here it will
tell us that this is the pentester lab
machine that we wanted which is correct
so now we want to do a vulnerability
analysis on this what we're going to do
is I'm going to use another GUI based
tool called Sparta which I can just find
out from here Sparta uses two tools in
the background a nmap tool and a tool
called nto so we just going to start
scanning 192 168
71133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the nto
to coming in scanning on Port 880 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells that it's an Apache
HT httpd
2.2.2 and that gives us the 22 port
number as well if we head over to the
tab of ncto or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website would be looking like and ncto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we going to do we go back
to the command line sorry we open up a
new one minimize all these other windows
and we going to open up metas sploit
Metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test uh
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metas in
this version so all of these are windows
based if we scroll up we will be looking
at other vulnerabilities as well or
exploits the unique space exploits LX
OSX multi exploits and we're looking for
a exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victims machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's a Linux operating system we want
this uh payload to be set so set payload
press enter that's the payload coming in
show options now that we have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payload as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
local host or lhost 192
16871 128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack you can see that
it has created a MPR session at the
victim site and it has opened up a
session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we
connected to v dub dubdub CGI hyphen bin
do an LS it will list all the files
that's the status file over there do a
CD backlash it will take us to the root
of this machine and if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security that is by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional well to switch careers with
cyber security by learning from the
experts then try giving a short to
Simply lears postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered Jude is waiting at the airport
to hop on her flight back home when she
realizes that she missed making an
important Bank payment she connects her
laptop to the public Wi-Fi at the
airport and goes ahead to carry out the
bank transaction everything goes well
and Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escaped the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber
attack Bank officials advise her to use
a VPN for future transactions especially
when connecting to an open or public
network like most of us Jude had come
across the term VPN several times but
didn't know much about it and little did
she think that the repercussions of not
using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process Jude's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP which provides
access to the internet she sends her
details to the bank's server using her
IP address Internet Protocol address or
IP address is a unique address that
recognizes a particular device be it a
laptop or a smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects Jude Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information such an
unsecured connection exposed judee's IP
address and Bank details to the hacker
when it passed through the public
network so would Jude have been able to
secure her transaction with the help of
a VPN well yes picture Jude's Bank
transaction to be happening in a tunnel
that is invisible to the hacker in such
a case the hacker will not be able to
spot a transaction and that is precisely
what a VPN does a virtual private
Network more often known as VPN creates
a secure tunnel between your device and
the internet for using a VPN Jude's
First Step would be to install
software-based technology known as the
VPN client on our laptop or smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the VPN client connects to to
the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts judee's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects judee's information from being
intercepted by the hacker Jude's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection
finally the VPN server connects to
judee's bank server in the last step
where the encrypted message is
decrypted this way judee's original IP
address is hidden by the VPN and the VPN
tunnel protects her data from being
hacked this explains how VPN makes your
data Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection after learning
about this Jude was certain that she
should start using a VPN to carry out
our online transactions in the future
this is also applicable to each one of
us even if you work remotely or connect
to public Wi-Fi using a VPN is the
safest option in addition to providing a
secure encrypted data transfer vpns are
also used to disguise your whereabouts
and give you access to Regional web
content VPN servers act as proxies on
the internet this way your actual
location cannot be established VPN
enables you to spoof your location and
switch to a server to another country
and thereby change your location for
example by doing so you can watch any
content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region meet
Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's
ideologies on one such occasion he could
not access a Global News website dealing
with uncensored information it seemed
his IP was blocked from visiting the
news website with his IP blocked
Jonathan turned to a popular proxy
service that was able to unblock the
news website thereby allowing an open
internet to all users just like how your
friend gives a proxy attendance for you
a proxy server serves as a standin user
to keep the real client private but what
is a proxy let's understand it's working
by taking a look at how Jonathan was
able to access geoblock content without
much hassle a proxy server acts as a
Gateway or intermediary server between a
user and its destination website when
Jonathan wasn't able to access the news
website he connected his system to a
global proxy server once connected the
proxy server assigns a new IP address to
Jonathan's system an IP address of a
different country where the website is
not censored following this process
whenever Jonathan visits that website
the website administrators see the new
IP address address assigned via proxy
server and sees no reason to deny access
to their account once the proxy server
is able to access the website it's
passed on to Jonathan's system via the
same channel regarding accessibility to
proxy servers you must first set it up
on your computer device or network next
check the steps required for your
computer or network as each operating
system has its setup procedures in most
cases however setup entails using an
automated configuration script there are
plenty of free proxy services available
on the internet however the safety of
such proxies is rarely verifi most free
proxies will provide an IP address and a
relevant port for connection purposes
reputed proxy providers like smart proxy
and bright data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step acts as authentication that
verifies an existing subscription on the
prod proxy provider server unlike free
providers that are open to all when it
comes to hiding IP addresses many people
consider a VPN to be the primary
solution while that's true up to some
extent there are a few things proxies do
differently in the case of vpns extra
encryption is also carried out to create
a secure tunnel between the user's
device and a VPN server a VPN is usually
much faster more secure thanks to
multiple layers of encryption and has
little to know downtime proxies tend to
be comparatively unsafe with the service
owners having the exact IP address of
the enduser and having no guarantees
regarding downtimes and
reliability if you want to know more
about how vpns work do watch how Jude
could have protected her banking
credentials using vpns in our detailed
video linked above now let's take a
small quiz to check how much we have
learned what can a VPN connection
provide that a proxy service cannot
a new IP address B multiple layers of
encryption C access to geoblock content
D authentication credentials think about
it and leave your answers Below in the
comment section and three lucky winners
will receive Amazon gift vouchers what
about the benefits of a proxy service
though besides allowing access to
blocked content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system they can also
filter content from thirdparty websites
allowing control over internet usage in
many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization on the Bas
proxy server the element of privacy
proxies provides is highly lucrative to
people looking to hide their actual IP
address from as many crying eyes as
possible one can easily argue the
benefits of using vpns over proxies for
added security measures however a few
basic tasks don't warrant maximum
privacy for the user side as in other
cases for example many consumers
worldwide find proxy Services more
convenient since all major operating
systems starting from Windows to Android
allow proxy configuration without the
hassle of installing new applications as
is in the case of a VPN in addition
there are services online that function
as web proxies allowing users to access
block content without any setup from
there end they can enter the target URL
and the web proxy will rout data from
its physical server this level of
freedom is hard to come by in the case
of vpns making proxies an ideal solution
for casual browsing with the next
generation of Internet exchanges focused
on maximum privacy and security a
variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain forces the standard
citizen to derive alternative ways to
maintain anonymity major weapon in this
battle for privacy and security is the
top browser an independent browser meant
to browse the internet while relaying
information through the Tor Network it
serves as a meaningful alternative to
the standard internet browsing habits to
better understand the purpose of this
browser and such you must learn about
the work of the T Network featuring its
own routing protocol the top browser is
an easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the Tet Network and its
significance in the working of the top
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the T browser and the
distinct advantages the tour Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a tour to
anonymize internet usage and finally we
have a live demonstration of the T
browser anonymize I ization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the T was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid rise in development
and innovation of digital products has
given way to frequent data breaches and
cyber thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the T
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the toet Network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user request Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the to network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different to relays
within the network the Tor Network uses
an onion routing technique for
transmitting data hence the original
name of onion router
to operate within the T Network a user
has to install the T browser any address
or information requested using the
browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
we will be covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is is transmitted
directly the sender has data package to
transmit which is done directly over a
line of communication with either a
receiving party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network apart from isps
there is a steady chance of your private
information being intercepted by hackers
unfortunately easy detection of the
source and contents of a web request
make entire network extremely vulnerable
for people who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the top browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
node decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
obfuscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the T browser was developed by a
nonprofit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced the to browser is
a browser Fork from the popular Firefox
that anonymizes your web traffic using
the to network if you're investigating a
competitor researching an opposing
litigant in a legal dispute or just
think it's creepy for your ISP or the
government to know what websites you
visit the to browser might be the right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers in and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the tour
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the T Network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service simil IL to
the links of the Deep Web these onion
links provide services like online
shopping cryptocurrency and many other
products not available in the consumer
Internet space often being considered as
a Haven for illegal activities and sales
onion links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously journalist
and dissidents around the world have
embraced t as a Cornerstone of democracy
and researchers are hard at work at
improving TS anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have open
source clients but the same cannot be
said for their counterparts
some have partly open source while some
have completely locked up their code so
that they cannot be stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the cender it goes through all of
those delay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one: one
between the client and a VPN as a next
Point since store handles multiple
layers of encryption and the data passes
through multiple systems along the way
the performance is slow compared to a
VPN where the performance is relatively
fast due to the less number of nodes the
data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
used T browser every single request
passes through the same layer of
encryption and follows the same routing
protocol when the case of a VPN
different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multihop
some prefer a single onetoone connection
and these kind of differences make the
choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward for inance in
the case of of vpns many such vpns are
hosted by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the T browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet
usage on opening up the tour browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the to
network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the tour browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the T browser will be little delayed and
the speed will will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session
if we just restart it once and we can
have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how we can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the tour Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over here
which is once again available only for
the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the to
network and this is used by mostly
journalists and people who want to
anonymize their internet transactions
when it comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at Great risk right hence fencing
our property helps safeguarded and keeps
trespassers at Bay similarly imagine our
computers and networks without
protection this would increase the
probability of hackers infiltrating our
networks to overcome this challenge just
like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in a gated community you would First
Take permission from the security guard
the security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed to entry
or not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion the role of the security
guard in this case is similar to that of
a firewall the firewall works like a
gatekeeper at your computer's entry
point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data packet and
thus protects your network from hackers
on the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network this way the firewall carries
out quick assessments to detect malware
and other suspicious activities thereby
protecting your network from being
susceptible to a Cyber attack firewalls
can either be Hardware or software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network linky routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall besides
this there are other types of firewalls
designed based on their traffic
filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the stateful inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet and
thereby prevents direct connections this
protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer after a
long gaming session Richard tries to
shut down but find some random text file
on the desktop that says Ransom note the
text file mentioned how a hacking group
had encrypted Richard's game files and
private documents and he had to pay a
ransom of $500 worth of bitcoin in a
specified Bitcoin address Richard
quickly checked his files only to see
them being encrypted and unreadable this
is the story of how the Tesla Crypt
ransomware spread in 2015 which affected
thousands of Gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so what is ransomware for Richard to be
targeted by such an attack he must have
installed applications from untrusted
sources or clicked an unverified link
both of them can function as gateways
for a ransomware breach ransomware is a
type of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password ATT text files available to
the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the ransom
note text file on his desktop even after
the money has been paid there's no
guarantee that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button above users tend
to click on unknown links receiv via
emails and chat applications promising
rewards of some nature once clicked the
ransomware files installed on the system
that encrypts all the files or blocks
access to computer functions they can
also be spread via malware transmitted
via untrusted application installation
or even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the Internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea apart from
system updates one must always have
reputed antivirus software installed
many antivirus software like kasperski
and Bit Defender have anti-ransomware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock symbol on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there is a website Noor ransom.
org it has a collection of decryption
tools for most well-known ransomware
packages it can also helped decrypt
specific encrypted files if the list of
anti-ransomware tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
pran viruses voms and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of of the malware programs
are designed to steal information from
the targeted user or to steal money from
the Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
troan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different file and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create back doors into a
system to allow the the cyper criminal
to steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan hor
functioning for Trojan hes entryway into
our system is through emails that may
look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the troit
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the masterb record
which is also known as MBR this damages
the boot sector section by targeting the
hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
microvirus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed the exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troin the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal our system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have exost
version they enter the system by
clicking the random popups which we come
across on the internet they attemp the
user to give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
offer system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affect the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and prion
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in
his
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option A microvirus option b
Ransom troen option C back door troan
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus Orion activity in
a system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the system then we
have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system for Trojan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction time then we have
there are more random popups from the
system which may indicate troan activity
and lastly we have modification in the
system application and change of the
desktop appearance can be also due to
the infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
troinos for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our
systems next for the troan hor we have
the emot troan program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for our
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
buge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any Trojan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comparison
to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troen
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just config
configuring the database itself so the
attacker at this point in time when they
send a query to the application will
form a malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on till this poers on I'm going to show
you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can
just look for OAS broken web application
project download you'll find it on
source for.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risk that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
VM workstation or Oracle virtual box and
you can uh then try your skills on it
right so uh just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71.1 32
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192 16871
132 and you'll see the oasp broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications inbuilt over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh OAS top 10
risks for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest
one so far
uh but the difference between 2013 and
2017 is that some of these have changed
but not all of them uh the order has
changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parro
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is pssw Rd I try
to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work I did
try type in a username and password it
wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to buy authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or 1 equals one space hyphen
hyphen space and I'm going to click on
login now right now I'm not logged in at
all and we tried our username and
password and we weren't able to log in
so now if I log in you will see that it
give me a status update saying the user
has been authenticated and I'm logged in
as admin got root so that is what the
SQL qu iies can achieve I'm going to log
out right now and uh we're going to look
at the basics of SQL injection so
looking at that small demo looking now
let's look at what types of SQL
injections are available so the first is
inband SQL injection the there are two
subtypes within inband error based
injection attack and a union based
injection attack the second type is
blind SQL injection attack where there's
a Boolean based and a Time based attack
and the third one is outof bound SQL
injection attack now what is inband SQL
injection attack inband is where you're
either attempting the error based or the
union based what is error based uh we
send a query to the database we craft a
query to the database and uh it
generates an error me message and it
dumps the error message right in front
of us on the screen that uh makes us
realize that there is a flaw and there
there is some information that is dumped
on the screen which we can then further
utilize to craft our further queries as
we go ahead whereas Union base is the it
is where we combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
URL earlier in the URL you would see a
large structure in that URL uh we can
try to add more two or more statements
within the URL itself to combine them
and then confuse the database into
executing both the statements together
and giving a data dum at the same time
right so what would a error based uh SQL
injection look like if I go back to the
same database uh which is here right and
if you remember the username we gave it
a single quote r 1 equal 1 space hyphen
hyphen space we gave it the condition
right so basically what it did was a
single code is an operator that goes to
the database selects the default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column
and then Compares it to the condition
that is given so the condition that we
gave was 1 equals 1 which is always true
so what it did was it selected the
default uh user table that was available
in the database and instead of comparing
it to a password it compared it to the
condition so if I give it 1 equals 2
where the condition is false and if I
log in you will see that the account
doesn't exist comes back again because
the condition was false and instead of
comparing the user account to the
password it basically uh compared the
user account to the condition so if I
give it a single quote or 1 equals 1
hyphen space uh and log in you can see
that this is a correct condition and
thus we are able to log in now before we
even go uh to that extent if I just
forget the condition over here and I
just give it a single code the operator
and I send this operator to the database
and I click on login you will see that
it generates an error which is right on
top and it tells us the line the uh file
where the error happened and you can see
it happened in the my SQL handler. PHP
file right and then it give us the
message you have an error in your SQL
syntax check the manual that corresponds
to your my SQL Server version for the
right syntax to use now why would a
hacker want to do this in the first
place because there are different types
of databases so there is a MySQL Ms SQL
or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM db2 all
of these are variations of the SQL
database uh they use the SQL language
however every database has its own
Command right they they have their own
syntax they have their own uh specific
commands that are utilized for the
database so in this scenario the hacker
wants to identify what database is being
currently utilized so they can craft
those particular queries so now with
this injection with just me sending the
quote and the error getting generated I
now come to know that we are using a
MySQL server and the version of that
server is 5.1. 73 and uh the rest of the
information about uh where the handlers
are located and so on so forth right
this gives the information to the hacker
of how they want to proceed next what
kind of queries they want to create what
kind of syntax they want to utilize so
error based attack is where you generate
these kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attack will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly worked what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from from this kind of an
information the hacker can infer their
next step forward then you have time
based sequel injections uh now there are
times when a database administrator an
application administrator has done some
security configuration and does have
disabled verbos error messages now what
is a verbos error message the error
message that we saw right here is a
verbos error message that means that the
message gives out details the message
gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if they have sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn
and
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbos error that we saw here
so this gives us a detail error of what
went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a Time based uh query in
the URL which allows us to verify
whether the command is being executed or
not so uh we put in a Time w wait let's
say 10 seconds of time weit so if we the
moment we inject the query if the query
times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that the SQL
injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheet for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server site you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've used it on quite a bit uh
here we have a example for gmail.com so
let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a c SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single code right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters passed into SQL
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
code was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilized in the first
place right so here what we are doing
here is a secure way of running a SQL
query in the jdbc using a parameterized
statement Define which user we want to
find so there's a string the email comes
in connection to the database we are
going to figure out how the connection
is going to be passed how it is going to
be created construct the SQL statement
we want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
and what can be passed to the database
and what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of uh
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use OB
object relational mapping Frameworks to
make the translation of SQL results set
into code objects more seus so this is
an example of object relational mapping
uh where we map certain objects and
allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs it a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to
uh basically ensure that these operators
cannot be accepted as user input if they
are they Ved out by the application and
they never reach the database other
methods of uh preventing SQL injection
are uh password hashing so that
passwords cannot be bypassed the
passwords cannot be recovered passwords
cannot be cracked uh third party
authentication you use o or some other
service for a single sign on mechanism
does uh you rely on a third party to
maintain the security of authentication
and uh what kind of parameters are past
for example uh using LinkedIn logins or
Facebook logins right uh for the Layman
you normally go on to Facebook and you
allow if you're using a game right if
you start playing a game you're allowed
to log into the game using your Facebook
credentials or your Google credentials
now that is not just for ease of use but
the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as Facebook or
Google because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is topnotch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks May may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the shot method of uh mitigating
or minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realized that the application has some
vulnerabilities for SQL injection and
instead of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities on the application don't
get
executed buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software you install it it's
going to be safe for Life new
vulnerabilities are discovered every day
every hour and it makes so happen what
is secure today may be completely
insecure tomorrow or the day after right
so you need to keep on upgrading the
software if there are no upgrades
available and the VAB still exist you
might want to migrate to a better
software and does uh ensure that you
don't get hacked right always update and
use patches organizations keep on
sending out updates and patches as and
when they are released you need to
install them to uh enhance your security
postures and then continuously monit SQL
statements and databases use protocol
monitors uh use different softwares use
the firewalls to keep on monitoring what
kind of queries you uh getting and based
on those queries you want to ensure the
inputs and the queries that are creating
uh are not detrimental to the health of
the software that you have Jane is
relaxing at home when she receives an
email from a bank that asks her to
update her credit card pin in the next
24 hours as a security measure judging
the severity of the message Janee
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
entailed credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our Mar case makes
Jane the fish and the fishing emails the
bait if Jane never opened the malicious
link or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of $100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers apart from
credit access some of these campaigns
Target the victim device and install
malware when clicked on the malicious
links which can later function as a botn
net or a target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of fishing attacks
the issue with Jane or the hacker stoer
Bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive fishing a general
email is sent out to thousands of users
in this category hoping some of them
fall prey to this scam spear fishing on
the other hand is a bit customized
version the the targets are researched
before being sent an email for example
if you never had a Netflix subscription
sending you an email that seems like the
Netflix Team sends it becomes pointless
this is a potential drawback of
deceptive fishing techniques on the
other hand a simple screenshot of a
Spotify playlist being shared on social
media indicates a probable point of
entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
priv information since the hacker
already knows the target uses Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10f which can be called
a case of wailing the hackers prepare
and wait for the right moment to launch
their fishing attack often to steal
industry secrets for rival companies or
sell them off at a higher price apart
from just emails farming focuses on fake
websites it sites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource const RS now that we know
how fishing attacks work let's look at
ways to prevent ourselves from becoming
victims while the implications of a
fishing attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or popup
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the users
browser forums message boards and online
pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then par this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript going to the fact that
JavaScript is most important to most
browser experiences nowadays
the main purpose of this attack is to
steal the other users identity be it via
cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as well
cross-side scripting is often compared
with similar client side attacks as
client side languages are mostly being
used during this however an xss attack
is considered riskier because of its
ability to damage even less vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window while
JavaScript is client site and does not
run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asly the manner of attack can range in a
variety of ways it can be a single link
which the user must click on to initiate
a JavaScript piece of code it can be
used to show any piece of images that
can be later used as a front end for
malicious code being installed as
malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting
let us learn more about how this kind of
attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately resist the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser but
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function the main reason for
this attack is inappropriate users input
valid Edition where the malicious input
can get into the output a malicious user
can enter a script which will be
injected onto the website's code then
the browser is not able to know if the
executed code is malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users there are many ways to
trigger an excesss attack for example
the execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when a use hovers over specific elements
of the page like hyperlinks potential
consequences of cross-site scripting
attacks include capturing key strokes of
a user redirecting a user to malicious
websites running web browser based
exploits obtaining cookie information of
a user who is logged into a website and
many more in some cases cross-side
scripting attack leads to complete
compromise of the victim's account
attackers can trick users into entering
credentials on a fake form which can
then provide all information to the
attacker with the basic working of a
cross-side scripting attack out of the
way let us go over the different ways
hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display fake
Pages or forms for the victim however
this can be performed in several ways we
have a reflected attack this attack
occurs when a malicious script is not
being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying fake
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser this
script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the strip and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code of script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored xss
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted via an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently stor in the web app the
users visiting the app after the
information retrieve the script the
malicious code then exploits the flaws
in the web application and the script
and the attack is visible on the server
side or to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform accss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious code that
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user site and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-site
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of ways one can
Safeguard against such attacks let's go
through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier excess
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent accessus attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application's live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected accss
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protect ing against accesses
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page rather than
trying to determine if the data is user
provided and could be compromised we
should always play it safe and Escape
data whether it is user provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-site
scripting clickjacking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports the flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flaw the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third
party if a browser does not support HTTP
only and a website attempts to set an
HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag will
be ignored byow the browser thus
creating a traditional script accessible
cookie as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable able to theft of modification
by any malicious script next on our
docket is a live demonstration where we
solve a set of cross-site scripting
problems starting from the basic level
to the topmost level six we're going to
start at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as as a
special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the
payload should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here
and we're going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-site scripting attack we can see
an alert box popup with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to Steel browser cookies and
passwords allbe it with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily accsess bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user injects
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross site
scripting attack is more powerful and it
is more riskier than reflect Ed crossed
scripting attacks and that's why is
known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of
here and check the index.html
file important
part is line
the generated HTML fragment which is the
HTML variable in the code is added to
the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parser will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
JavaScript we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we're
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an onerror event
in on error event the it will execute
our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the URL
is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall into to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once visit that URL we can see that our
Java popup has opened up here with the
same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this for application there is
a timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished
and we can see the time is a popup
appearing over here and this resets the
timer again now it is obvious that the
value entered in the text box is
transferred to the server over the timer
parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start time method is being called
in the onload event however the timer
parameter is being directly passed to
the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without
breaking the JavaScript code the
parameter value is directly added to the
start timer method without any filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be executed inside
the on loan event along with the start
timer method
we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
completed we can now move on to level
five
in this web application this application
xss is different cuz this challenge
description says cross-side scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an un expected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected the href attribute value of
next link is confirm which is exactly
the value of the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means you using the next query parameter
can be used to inject a JavaScript code
to the href attribute of the next link
the following is the best way to do it
as soon as the user clicks on the link
the script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level six
in this sub application it shows some of
the external Javascript is
rried if you analyze the URL you can see
that the script is loaded already the
vulnerability lies within how the code
handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being created that is with this
vulnerability we can inject our own
JavaScript file into the code we can
inject a URL of our own hosted
JavaScript into the web application's
URL after the hashtag and the URL should
not be using https but anything like
that to bypass the regular expression
for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
JavaScript
file finally we have reached the end of
our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
use different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's error people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a DS
attack these DS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to bot net farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conducted
by Chinese authorities this attack went
on for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition it was the strongest DS attack
to date at the time and made a lot of
companies reconsider the security
practices to combat such attacks even
after years of EXP experimentation DS
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space hey everyone this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a DS attack let's learn
more about what is a DS
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything ser servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to server page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center the Bots in
the network attack a particular Target
thereby hiding the original perpetrator
of the Dos campaign but how do these
devices come under a botnet and what are
the requests being made to the web
servers let's learn more about these and
how DS attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or
zombies in the second phase a particular
Target is selected for the attack when
the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests to the
Target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service
inoperable there is a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of Dos
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus and clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next next we have the protocol
level attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include s
and floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application lay attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in requests per second these
are relatively sophisticated attacks
that Target the application and
operating system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network banded up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking a
single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a dors attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a DS attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while DS attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use dedos attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemma or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individuals can
protect themselves against three do
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load balances
reroute the traffic from one server to
another in a DS attack this reduces the
single point of failure and adds
resiliency to the server data a firewall
blocks unwanted traffic into a system
and manages es the number of requests
made at a definite rate it checks for
multiple attacks from a single IP and
occasional slowdowns to detect a DS
attack in
action early detection of a DS attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious dor traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here here
where you will filter the traffic so
that only legitimate traffic reaches the
server by intelligent routing you can
break the remaining traffic into
manageable chunks that can be handled by
your cluster resources the most
important stage in DOS mitigation is
where you will look for patterns of Ros
attacks and use those to analyze and
strengthen your mitigation techniques
for example blocking an IP that's
repeatedly found to be offending is a
first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and
networks from dos criminals the cloud
also has greater bandwidth than most
private networks so it is likely to fail
if under the pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
DS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of DS attacks on a system for
our demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a Dos
attack of sorts once a botet is ready
multiple devices can do the same and
eventually emulate a DS attack to do so
we will use the virtualization software
called VMware with an instance of parro
security operating system running for a
Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use wire shark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is parro
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168 .
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will be have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool called
hping3
hping 3 is an open- Source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
wi shark is a network traffic analyzer
you can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light drro is
being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to once once we
have the Dos attack launched you can see
the results coming over here from The
Source IP which will be par security Now
to launch the hping 3 command we need to
give PSE sudo access to the console
which is the root
access now we have the root access for
the console the hping 3 command will
have a few arguments to go with it which
are as you can see on the screen
minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is21 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shockk it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1 128
till now even the network is responsive
and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a back end
now remember Linux light is a drro and
such Linux dros are served as backend to
many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack now the system has become
completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security we can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos ATT ATT as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now when a Dos attack multiple systems
such as multiple Pirro security
instances or multiple zombies or bots in
a bot nut Network can attack a Target
server to completely shut down the
machine and drop any legitimate request
thereby rendering the service and the
target completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
like to remind that this is for
educational purposes only and we do not
endorse any attacks on any domains only
test this on servers and networks that
you have permission to test on cyber
security has become one of the most
rigid Industries in the last decade
while simultaneously being the most
challenged with every aspect of
corporate culture going online and
embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one boot Force attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
following prey to Brute Force attacks
are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
deal although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data aisc are used and
at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
where the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones they omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient Bru
Force attack since running all the
combination with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer rather than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
and easy to use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
you can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam
this reduces the chance of circling back
the source to a single device which
belongs to the hacker once brute forced
A system can spread malware via email
attachments sharing links file upload
via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to imperson the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the is we
can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of withstanding Brute
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or a password
is compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific tofa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2 course
are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since boot Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably a definite rule that lcks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation the world has gone Wireless
with WiFi taking the re in every
household it's natural that the security
will always be up for debate to further
tou the security index and understand
Brute Force attacks we will attempt to
break into the password of a Wi-Fi
router for that to happen we first need
to capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the Wi-Fi router to
a connecting Dev device like a mobile or
a laptop the operating system used for
this process is parot security a Linux
distribution that is cater to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and its name is now dou l0
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
56 26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C we will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a. cap file for the path
we can let's say we can keep it in a
desktop okay we give the
path and the hand shap file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will aut
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
all already know let's say that the
password is at least 10 digits you can
go with the minimum length as 10 and as
a rough guess let's say we put the
maximum length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this pass phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
trying every single combination you can
see the last the fourth character from
the right side the D it will eventually
turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the wp2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
this is the way we can Brute Force into
Wi-Fi routers anywhere in the world
cyber attacks are frequently making
headlines in today's digital environment
at any time everyone who uses a computer
could become a victim of a Cyber attack
there are various SS of cyber tanks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botet but before
we begin if you love watching Tech
videos subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon never to miss an update to
begin with let's take a look at some of
the famous Boton
attacks the first one is Mir bot which
is a malicious program designed to
attack vulnerable iot devices and infect
them to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks then we have
the zoos bot is specifically designed
for attacking the system for Bank
related information and data now let's
see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot harder remotely
controls them the bards are used to
automate large scale attacks including
Data Theft server failure malware
propagation and denial of service
attacks
now that we know what exactly a bot net
is let's dive deeper into learning how
bot net works during the preparation of
a botet network the first St involves
preparing the bot net Army after that
the connection between the botn net Army
and the control server established and
the end the launching of the attack is
done by the bot Herer let's understand
through a
illustration firstly we have a bot Herer
that in initiates the attack according
to the control server commands the
devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a bot net is to infect as
many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates BS either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through Trojan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
bot server a bot Herer uses command
programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to atmin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the
important
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the bot Herer issues a command
to the server it is then relate to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
PE controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the Bots are topological
interconnected and acts as both C and C
servers that is the server and the
client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certified
antivirus anti- spyware softwares and
firewall installed into system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as ke loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
to understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effect effects that key logging can
bring into the system to begin with we
learn what exactly the key logging
program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the
system searching for a suable driver for
a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key loging ISS issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key logging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key loging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
our keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its original for malicious
purposes each time we press a key the
key logger intercepts the signal and
logs it then we have form grabbing based
key loggers as the name suggests they
are a based key loggers that store the
form data that is if we often use web
forms or different kinds of forms to
enter different data they can be
recorded into the system by the program
and send it to its
origin then we have colel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand device say
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to to the exploitation of
data that includes photos emails or
important files by the hacker or the
Cyber criminal that install the
particular malicious program into the
system now to prevent a system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the the important
libraries that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next next part we'll write
a piece of code that will allow us to
save the data that is recorded by the
program into our text file that will be
named as key log text file along with
the date and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name
that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as along with the time
stamp
as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above line
and
logging the Press
key
info or string file to be
recorded into the loog file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release
that will come into play
when the Escape key has been pressed
that is the program will terminate
itself and the program will stop from
running
and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle that will be going for while press
and
on
release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is the text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is a hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key loggers are then
we understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key logging problem then we learn
how to detect the problem into our
system then we learn what different
types of key log are present on the net
we also understood how hackers use the
recorded data from the program and we
also learned whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system and before we begin if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts then
try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
before we learn about the Pegasus
platform let us understand what spyware
is and it's working spyware is a
category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spyware
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spy system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location R text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video
Pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any client that
wishes to buy its services initially the
NSO group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security unfortunately the
people who bought the software had
complete control over who how and up to
what level they can put surveillance
limits on eventually the primary clients
became Sovereign Nations spying on
Public Information that is supposed to
stay private became really easy with
this service multiple devices can be
affect With the same spy system to
create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus spyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the Spy is successfully installed
the perpetrator who sent the payload to
the victim can monitor everything the
user does Pegasus can collect private
emails passwords images videos and every
other piece of information that passes
to the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex Spy software like Pegasus
can access the root files on our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating systems leaking such
private information is a massive blow to
the security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or researcher once they
are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would would be either
Google for Android or Apple for iOS is
the right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the gate
to for pyware to enter into the system
you can never be 100% safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where Pegasus stands out
is a zero click action feature usually
in spam emails the malicious code is
activated when the user clicks the
malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
Pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
WhatsApp Gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
Ed and everything can be recorded and
sent back to the central server the
primary issue with being affected by
spyware as a victim is detection unlike
Crypt Miners and Trojans spying Services
usually do not demand many system
resources which makes them tough to
detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longetivity
by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if you are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall free to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big spare
on the market let's say we are safe now
and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple with send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spy platform alt together
another big factor is the spread of of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using APK files
downloading such apps from a thirdparty
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted website ites and not click on
any links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false ve of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it's stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar winds attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is De December 8th 2020
fire a global leader in company
specializing in cyber security released
a blog post that caught the attention of
the entire it Community a software known
as Orion which was developed by solar
wind Incorporated had become a victim of
a remote access strojan or a rat the
breach was estimated to be running since
the spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fix access for the platform in
order to mitigate this threat and
prevent further damage but how did this
come into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion cering to
corporations and governments worldwide
Orion was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are prefer services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for soloin
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers pack
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believe the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issues
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar wind hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
erne's Microsoft 365 email accounts as
part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper the day is
26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
collective in movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory in the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life Meed
out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120,000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35,000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War a digital assault
or series of strikes or hacks against a
country is sometimes referred to as a
cyber War it has the ability to cause
havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupted
essential systems causing State harm and
even debt in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions
so rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber War has become the new
means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves a
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer War
design to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague applying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage Espionage and tells monitoring
other countries to steal critical
Secrets this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botn
Nets or spear fishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare the next weapon in cyber war is
sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forcing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties may use
this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a Country Split print
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is involved in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked having
devices segregated in a network goes a
long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defis and if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security that is by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional where he sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box box that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered during data transmission
there are various external factors which
can affect the transmission of data over
a network channel to prevent such cases
from happening we use Internet Protocol
security which we'll be discussing in
the session on IPC explain hi guys and
welcome to EET de testing video by
simply learn but before we begin if you
are watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
miss an update from us now without
further Ado let's take a look at the
agenda for this
session to begin with we will look into
what is
IPC continuing with why do we use IPC in
a
network followed by components of
IPC modes of Ip security as for the last
topic we will look into working steps
involved in IP security let's begin with
the first setting that is what is IP sec
IPC Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network
channel this protocol was initially
defined of two main protocols for data
security over a network channel which
were authentication header which is
responsible for data integrity and
anti-replay
services and the second protocol is
encapsulating security payload in short
ESP which includes data encryption and
data
authentication now let's move on to the
next setting that is why do we use IPC
in a
network IPC is used to secure sensitive
data and information such as company
data clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution which are used during data
transmission over a network channel
the use of VPN that are virtual private
networks and apply IPC protocols to
encrypt the data for inin
transmission let's continue with why do
we use IPC
Services IPC is also used to encrypt
data for application layer in the OSI
model and provide security for sharing
data over Network routers and data
authentication let's take a look at the
working of ipx
services to begin with we have two
different system system 1 and system 2
which will establish a network channel
and then the encryption of data will
takes place when one host will share the
data to the second host during this ipx
services will secure the data that is to
be transferred over the network channel
by applying router encryption and
Authentication now let's move on to the
next topic that is components of
IPC the IPC Services comprises of
multiple protocols that ensure the data
transmission over the network channel
the first one is encapsulating security
payload protocol in short
ESP this protocol of Ip security
provides data encryption and
authentication
services and it also authenticates and
encrypt the data packet in the trans
Miss
Channel moving on we have authentication
header in short
ah similar to es the authentication
header also provides all the security
services but it does not encrypt the
data it also protects the IP packet and
adds additional headers to the packet
header the modified IP datagram looks
this way where the IP components are
included at the second position the
seventh position and the sixth position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network
channel moving on we have Internet key
exchange ik
ke this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes the
attribute of the original data to be
shared by implementing sha and md5
algorithms they also check the message
for authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver site for
example this is the original data packet
we are used to with IP header TCP UDP
and data whereas this is the modified IP
site data packet where a ESP header is
added between IP header and the TCP
protocol now let's move on to the next
heading that is modes of Ip
SEC there are basically two types of ips
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel where the first
one is turn mode this mode of
transmission is used to secure gateway
to Gateway data it is applied when the
final destination of the data is to be
connected to a sender site through a
connection Gateway over the Internet for
example we have two host host a and host
B through the host a we are sending a
message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point and it
passes through a gateway to host B then
this is a basic format for Gateway to
Gateway data
transmission and the given IP datagram
format is used for tunnel mode now let's
move on to the second mode of Ip SEC
that is transport mode this mode of IPC
is used to protect protocols like TCP or
UDP and is used to ensure end to end
communication unlike tunnel mode mode
the transport mode data at
authentication header and encapsulating
security payload for security purpose in
the IP
header this is the modified IP datagram
for transport mode the point to be noted
is the IP SEC header is always added
between IP header and TCP
header now let's move on to the last
heading for the session on IP SEC that
is the working steps involved in IP
security
in general there are five steps involved
in the working of Ip sec to ensure data
transmission over a network
channel the first step is host
recognition in the first step the host
system will check if the pket is to be
transmitted or Not by automatically
triggering the security policy for the
data which is implemented by the sender
side for proper
encryption then the second step is known
as ik Phase 1 in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver site
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network
channel it is comprised of two modes the
main mode this provides much better
security with a proper time
limit and the second mode known as
aggressive mode as the name suggests it
establishes the IPC protocol much faster
in comparison to main mode let's move on
to the third step which is ik Phase 2
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for
transmission then we have IP
transmission this step involves the
actual transfer of data over the network
channel using various protocols used in
ipx security which are implemented under
the tunnel condition and the last step
is IPC termination after the completion
of data exchange or session timeout the
IPC tunnel is terminated and the
security key established is discarded by
both the host system network security is
a set of technologies that protects the
usability and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secured dat the loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system the
workstations are protected from
hazardous F thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the middle
attacks preventing situation like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and
authorization the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network is trying to access or enter
it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example the network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network user's role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat and environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtime can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential mention that these protection
measures are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
stored data that ensure the acceptance
of rules and regulations as a whole
there are three types the first of which
is physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative let's look into phys
physical security first this is the most
basic level that includes protecting
data and network to unauthorized
Personnel from acquiring control over
the confidentiality of the network these
include external peripherals and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the Network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggest necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties through the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app player security can
lead to Performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken on examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
service attacks or DDOS attacks HTTP
floods Hill injections cross-site
scripting Etc most organizations have an
arsenal of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web Gateway services Etc now that we
have the theory behind network security
has been covered in detail let us go
through some of the tools that can be
used to enforce these network security
policies the first two to be covered in
the section is a firewall a firewall is
a type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules for more than
25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some point
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for short it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet the
encrypted connection AIDS the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to e drop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of VN
technology is common in both corporate
and personal networks next we cover the
importance of intrusion prision systems
in network security or IPS Frameworks an
intrusion prevention system is a network
security tool that continually scans a
network for harmful activity and
responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it it
can be either Hardware or software it's
more sophisticated than an intution
detection system or an IDs framework
which can just warn an administrator and
merely identify harmful activities while
in the case of an IPS it actually takes
against that activity the next tool in
this section and the final one are going
to be behavioral analytics Behavior
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage on
some kind of similar pattern is noted
whe the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go through the
benefits of network security as a
whole the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the offenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these bad factors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert attacks are getting a
strong cyber security posture that
considers routine software updates May
assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity
it is nearly impossible for employees to
function when networks and personal
devices are slow to a crawl by viruses
and other cyber attacks during the
operation of website and for the company
to run you must significantly minimize
violations and the amount of downtime
required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyaly
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on a personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet an an wanted to look
for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she had failed to
notice that the website was a HTTP web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping and
I including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has crypted transactions and
employees cryptography our iPhone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action let's Now
understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand understand the message as an
essential aspect of modern data security
using cryptography allows the Secure
Storage and transmission of data between
willing parties encryption is a primary
route for employing cryptography by
adding certain algorithms to Jumble up
the data decryption is the process of
reversing the work done by encrypting
information so that the data becomes
readable again both of these methods
form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word thereby reversing the process
of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tool
tools these algorithms are called
ciphers they are a set of detailed steps
to be carried out one after the other to
make sure the data becomes as unreadable
as possible until it reaches the
receiver we take the plain text pass it
to the cipher algorithm and get the
encrypted data this encrypted text is
called the cipher text and this is the
message that is transferred between the
two parties the key that is being used
to scramble the data is known as the
encryption key these steps that is is
the cipher and the encryption key are
made known to the receiver who can then
reverse the encryption on receiving the
message unless any third party manages
to find out both the algorithm and the
secret key that is being used they
cannot decrypt the messages since both
of them are necessary to unlock the
hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend
encryption there is a huge Market
opening up for cryptocurrency which is
possible due to blockchain technology
that uses encryption algorithms and
hashing functions to ensure that the
data is secure if this is of particular
interest to you you can watch our video
on blockchain the link of which will be
in the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice they are
symmetric encryption asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your an is
in the comments and before we proceed if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up before
moving ahead let's look at symmetric
encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar Cipher and
igma machine are both symmetric
encryption examples that we will look
into further for example if Alice wants
to send a message to Bob she can apply a
substitution shifer or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into Cipher text stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
Cipher text one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorith
is AES 256 that stands for advanced
encryption standard which has a key size
of 256bit with 128bit and 196 bit key
sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with the
public key and the decryption is done
with a private key that no one except
Bob has access to both the keys are
necessary to read the full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decp the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Edelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat
applications with so much hanging on the
key secrecy there must be a way to
transmit the keys without others reading
our private data many systems use a
combination of symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption to bolster
security and match speed at the same
time since asymmetric encryption takes
longer to decrypt large amounts of data
the full information is encrypted using
a single key that is symmetric
encryption that single key is then
transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffy helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
of messing up the data collection form
the hash function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in Blain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a I can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use a substitution shift
of plus two a becomes c b becomes D and
so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes dww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately name the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the Nazi German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we received the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while we browse
the internet thanks to cryptography here
we have a web based tool that will help
us understand the process of RSA
encryption we see the entire workflow
from selecting the key size to be used
until the decryption of the cipher text
in order to get the plain text back as
we already know RSA encryption algorithm
falls under the umbrella of asymmetry
key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to encp the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a 512
bit to 1,24 bit all the way up to a 496
bit key the longer the key length the
more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operator past freezes the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt a word
simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over
here the sud random generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different Cipher
text this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption
process once you click decrypt you can
see the original playe text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decription let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures the
data Y shck is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leaving a machine and to understand
how vulnerable it
is since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over
here let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials these obviously won't work
but we can see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand what request this
website is
sending these are the requests being
sent by the HTTP login form to the
internet if we check here see whatever
username and password that we are
entering we can e easily see it with the
wire shark now we used a dummy pair of
credentials if we select the right data
packet we can find our correct
credentials if any website had asked for
a payment information or a legitimate
credentials it would have been really
easy to get a hold of these to reiterate
what we have already learned we must
always avoid HTTP websites and just
unknown or not trustworthy websites in
general because the problem we saw here
is just the tip of the iceberg even
though cryptography has manage to lessen
the risk of cyber attacks it is still
prevalent and we should always be alert
to keep ourselves safe online there are
two types of encryption in
cryptography symmetric key
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography both of these categories
have their pros and cons and differ only
by the implementation today we are going
to focus exclusively on symmetry key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boost
the security index of these payment
gateways in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no
delay while browsing the internet we
need symmetric encryption to browse
secure https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security this helps us in
preventing the rather insecure HTTP
website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms symmetric key cryptography
relies on a single key for the
encryption and decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into Cipher text and vice
versa as as you can see in the image the
key used for encryption is the same key
needed for decrypting the message at the
other end the secret key shouldn't be
sent along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the Diffy Helman
key exchange protocol for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to deip the cipher
text once it reaches her irrespective of
the scenario where someone manages to
grab the cipher text mid transit to try
and read the message not having the
secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snop in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s while the popular ones like the
AES have become the industry standard
today with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on all
locasion the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
decryption key private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
key secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetric
key cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream ciphers are the algorithms
that encre basic information one bit at
a time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most popular ones are the
rc4 salsa and Panama the binary data is
passed through an encryption key which
is a randomly generated bitstream upon
passing it through we receive the cipher
text that can be transferred to the
receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks the binary data can be
passed through an algorithmic function
it can have either X or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
Cipher
text on the other hand block ciphers
dissect the raw information in into
chunks of data of fixed size the size of
these blocks depend on the exact Cipher
being used a 128bit block Cipher will
break the plane text into blocks of
128bit each and encrypt those blocks
instead of a single digit once these
blocks are encrypted individually they
are chained together to form a final
Cipher
text block ciphers are much slower but
they are more tamper proof and are used
in some of the most widely used
algorithms employed
today just like stream ciphers the
original Cipher text is converted into
binary format before beginning the
process once the conversion is complete
the blocks are passed to the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us with the encrypted
blocks of binary
data once these blocks are combined we
get a final binary
string this string is then converted
into hexadecimal format to get a cipher
text today the most popular symmetric
key algorithms like AES Dees and 3des
are all block Cipher methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some
other symmetrically cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric cryptography there is only
one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption similarly the performance of
symmetric encryption is much more
efficient under similar computational
limitations fewer calculations help in
better memory management for the host
system bulk amounts of data that need to
be encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mix
brackets thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetry key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday Communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can enip
vast amounts of data with very less
overhead Dees algorithm stands for data
encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a block by block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they later chained together to form our
final Cipher text which is then sent to
a receiver DS takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plane
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encryptor text that is
called the cipher text it uses 48 bit
Keys during the encryption process and
follows a specific structure called the
fistal Cipher structure during the
entire process it is a symmetri key
algorithm which means DS can reuse the
keys used in the encryption format to
decrypt the cipher text back to the
original plane text once the 64-bit
blocks are encrypted they can be
combined together before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason Dees was
founded Dees s is based on a fistal
block Cipher called Lucifer developed in
1971 by IBM cryptography researcher host
fistal DS uses 16 rounds of this fistal
structure using a different key for each
round it also utilizes a random function
with two inputs and provides a single
output
variable DS becames the organization's
approved encryption standard in November
1976 and was later reaffirmed as a
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in 19
99 but eventually DS was cracked and it
was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds is a symmetri key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds CER
encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with the third key there
is also a variation of the two keys
where the first and second key are
duplicate of each other but triple Ds
was ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time DS
was the standard for data encryption for
data security
its rule ended in 2002 when finally the
advanced encryption standard replaced
Dees as an acceptable standard following
a public competition for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exord
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual ual round
this keeps going on until the last step
until where the right hand side and the
left hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrimental
to the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was
compromised a fistal block CER is a
structure used to derive many symmetric
block ciphers such as DS which as we
have discussed in our previous
comment pistal Cipher proposed a
structure that implements substitution
and permutation alternately so that we
can obtain Cipher text from the plain
text and vice versa this helps in
reducing the redundancy of the program
and increases the complexity to combat
Brute Force
attacks the fistal Cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in 1945 the fistel cipher is
the structure suggested by horse F still
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers the Shannon structure highlights
the implementation of alternate
confusion and diffusion and like we
already discussed the fistal Cipher
structure can be completely reversed
depending on the data however we must
consider the fact that to decrypt the
information by reversing the Fel
structure we will need the exact
polinomial functions and the key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculator we take a plane testt
which is of 64bit and that is later
divided into two equal halves of 32bit
each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second round the right hand is again
passed off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever the
function gives off as an output it is
passed on as an xor input with the left
half of the initial plane text the next
output will become the right half of the
second round for the plane text this
entire process constitutes of a single
round in the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in the polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32-bit to
48-bit text this is done to make the
text compatible to a 48-bit keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass it to the EXO
function we get a 48-bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32-bit so this 48-bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later data exort with the first
half of the plane
text a block Cipher is considered the
safest if the size of the block is large
but large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
Street generally the size is
64-bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block server
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher Al way we must maintain
maintain a balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it it cannot be
implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of Fel
ciphers we can take a look at how Dees
manages to run through 16 rounds of the
structure and provide the cipher text at
the end
now that we understand the basics of FAL
cyers we can take a look at how DS
manages to run through 16 rounds of this
structure and provide a cipher text in
simple terms DS takes a 64-bit plane
text and converts it into a 64-bit
Cipher text and since we are talking
about asymmetric algorithms the same key
is being used when it is decrypting the
data as
well we first take a 64bit ke plane text
and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the inial
permutation function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fistal Cy
structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the DS algorithm namely 16
rounds of FAL Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bit Keys is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the rounds are
swapped and we get our final Cipher text
this is the entire process of De s with
16 rounds of his ciphers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text back to the
plane text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Dees the bonus when it comes
to speed but eventually it was
detrimental to the overall efficiency of
the program when it comes to security
factors BS have five different modes of
operation to choose from this one of
those is electron code book each 64-bit
block is encrypted and decrypted
independently in the electronic codebook
format we also have Cipher block
chaining or the CBC method here each
64-bit block depends on the previous one
and all of them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a su a
random output which in turn is exor with
the plain text
there is an output feedback method as
well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
Dees a counter method has a different
way of approach where each plain text
block is exor with an encrypted counter
the counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
DS the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
20130 n also had to change the DS
algorithm because its key length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56 bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard does
not mean that it is no longer in use
triple Ds is still used today and is
still considered a legac encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and Cipher Tex look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is mandatory this
key can be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the keys settled we provide
the plain text or the clear text that
needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose a sentence
for this example is this is my first
message we have satisfied two
prerequisites the message and the key
another variable that goes into play is
the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher Tex block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get
corrupted regarding the manner of
displaying binary information we have
two options here we can either go with
base 64 or the heximal format let's go
with the base 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hex so we will be getting
a smaller Cipher text when it comes to
base
64 B the size of both the formats will
be the same the hex has a longer Cipher
text since B 64 takes four characters
for every three bytes while hex will
take two characters for each B hence B
64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the CER text we
go by the same format choose base
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is BAS 64
in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
stand is still on top when it comes to
symmetric encryption security and will
likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to safeguard a
personal data as solid as Dees was the
computers of today could easily break
the encryption with repeated attempts
thereby rendering the data security
helpless to counter this dilemma a new
standard was introduced which was termed
as the advanced encryption standard or
the AES algorithm
let's learn what is Advanced encryption
standard the AES algorithm also known as
the reenal algorithm is a symmetric
block Cipher with a block size of 128
bits it is converted into Cipher text
using keys of 128 192 or 256 bits it is
implemented in software and Hardware
throughout the world to encrypt
sensitive data the National Institute of
Standards and Technology also known as
nist started development on AES in 1997
when it was announced the need for an
alternative to the data encryption
standard the new internet needed a
replacement for Dees because of its
small key size with increasing computing
power it was considered unsafe against
entire key search attacks the triple Ds
was designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
by the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used its selection was
formalized with the release of federal
information processing standards
publication 197 in the November of 2001
it was approved by the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
feature that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm uses a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher text it has a series of
linked operations including replacing
inputs with specific outputs that is
substitutions and others that involve
bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 92 bit key or 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on bite data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the DS
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is input into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in AES
before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into four Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be trans transferred into the
next
round it is a 16 byte Matrix with each
cell representing one bite with each
four bytes representing a word so every
state array will have a total of four
words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n n + 1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n + one
rounds it is also a state array having
four words in its vicinity every key is
used for a single round and the first
key is used as a round key before any
round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exor function with a round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mixed column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round
the last four steps mentioned are part
of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skip the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plain textt
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
as per iteration
demands the state aray is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then passed office input to the sub byes
process in the second stage we have bite
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into a heximal value
having two parts the first part denotes
the row value and the second part
denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the SBX to
create a brand new state array which is
then passed off as an input to the row
shifting process the 16 input bytes are
replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four columns
s when it comes to row shifting each bit
in the four rows of the Matrix is
shifted to the left an entry that is a
falloff is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mix columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematical function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs for completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration
when it comes to adding a round key the
16 bytes of the Matrix are treated as
128 bits and the 128 bits of the round
key are exort if it is the last round
the output is the cipher text if it
still have a few rounds remaining the
resulting 128 bits are interpreted as 16
bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if part plane text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a heximal
format as follows we use an encryption
key which is that's my K Fu and it is
converted into a hexadecimal format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n+ one number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exor with the k0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution byes
process when it comes to the
substitution byes process we leverage an
SBX to substitute the elements of each
bite with a completely new bite this way
the state array that we receive is
passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three the state array that we received
from the row shifting is passed off as
an input to mix columns in mix columns
we multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new state are to be passed on onto the
next step
we add the name State array as an exor
with the round key of the particular
iteration whatever state array we
receive here it becomes an output for
this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we fin finally receive a
cipher
text once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Rials
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for communication
AES is also prevalent in general file
encryption of various formats ranging
from critical documents to the media
files having a large key allows people
to encrypt media and decrypt data with
maximum security
possible a is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a
look when it comes to key length the
biggest flaw in DS algorithm was that
small length was easily vulnerable by
today's standards AES has managed to NAB
up 128 192 and 256bit key lens to
bolster the security further the block
size is also larger in AES owing to more
complexity of the algorithm the number
of rounds in Dees is fixed irrespective
of the plain text being used in AES the
number of round depends on the key
length that is being used for the
particular iteration thereby providing
more Randomness and complexity in the
algorithm the DS algorithm is considered
to be simpler than AES even though AES
beats Dees when it comes to relative
speed of encryption and decryption this
makes Advanced encryption standard much
more streamlined to be deployed in
Frameworks and systems worldwide when it
compares to the data encryption standard
hello in our last video on cryptography
we took a look at symmetric key
cryptography we used a single private
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data and it works very
well in theory let's take a look at a
more realistic scenario now let's meet
Joe Joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with Ryan via longdistance
messaging due to the critical nature of
the information people are waiting for
any message to leave Joe's house so that
they can intercept it now Joe can easily
use symmetric K cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetric
key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on asymmetri key cryptography
let's take a look at what we are going
to learn today We Begin by explaining
what asymmetric ke cryptography is and
how it works we take a look at its
application and uses we understand why
it's called publicy cryptography and
then learn a little bit about RS
encryption and then we learn about the
advantages of asymmetry key cryptography
over symmetry key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information pre-
Transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must belong to the receiver of
the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions as
you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plain text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public key known to
everyone cannot be used to decrypt the
message and the private key which can
Decap the message need not be shared
with anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you in a way you
can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to decrypt the data in
another example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob let's say tre's call me
today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decp the message and hence complete
Security is attained during transmission
without any need for sharing the
key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signature so there is valid
proof of a document's authenticity with
so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private Keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with with duplicate Keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetri key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain peer-to-peer Network only if
it is approved from both ends along with
the symmetri key cryptography stamp
approve architecture it's non reparation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network
stable we can also use asymmetrically
cryptography combined with symmetric
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric enry ion being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original
message is first encrypted using a
symmetric key the key used for
encrypting the data is then converted
into the cipher text using the
receiver's public key now we have two
Cipher text to transmit to the receiver
on receiving both of them the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
Symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just Asm symmetric cryptography
alone symmetric encryption algorithms
are much more optimized for vast amounts
of data on some occasions encrypting the
key using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private unlike symmetry key cryptography
there is no need to share anything
privately to have an encrypted messaging
system to put that into perspective we
share our email address with anyone
looking to communicate with us it is
supposed to be public by Design so that
our email login credentials are private
and they help in preventing any data
mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetri
cryptography none more famous than the
RSA
encryption RSA encryption is the most
widely used encryption or public ke
encryption standard using asymmetry key
approach named after its Founders reest
Shamir and Adelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
they are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the block size depends on the
exact Cipher being used once they are
broken down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption or B it
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies let's go through some of
them there is no need for any reliable
key sharing channel in asymmetric
encryption it was an added risk in
private key cryptography that has been
completely eliminated in public key
architecture the key which is made
public cannot Rec any confidential
information and the only key that can
decrypt doesn't need to be shared
publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lens in RSA encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit key
and 496 bit Keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more
secure asymmetric key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
to be reversed encryption is done using
a private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the
owner it also has a tamper protection
feature where the message cannot be
intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data consequently the public
key cannot decrypt the message and it is
easy to realize the information is not
100% legitimate when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving on to the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetry key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with the private key for
digital signatures however the reverse
is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are ink
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document thereby
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in Step One we have M which
is the original plain text message and
it is passed onto a hash function
denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the message
together with a hash digest and encrypts
it using the sender's private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
senders public
key once the message is De scripted it
is passed through the same hash function
H hash to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secure Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signature are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret further some
non-repudiation schemes offer for a time
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DS algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
stand standard which is a federal
information processing standard for
digital signatures it was proposed in
1991 and globally standardized in 1994
by the National Institute of Standards
and Technology also known as the nist it
functions on the framework of modular
exponation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
signed the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
impose less load on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or Decap
message digest using public key instead
it uses mathematical functions to create
a digital signature consisting of two
160 bit numbers which are originated
from the message digests and the private
key DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSM DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed pass onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable G of
random variable K and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver and we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest it is
passed onto verification function which
has other requirements such as the
publicy of the sender Global variable G
and SNR received from the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if the
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works we already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a queue which
becomes a prime devisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now once these values are selected
we can go ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by X and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of Z and the value
of Q the public key can be calculated as
y = to G ^ x mod P where y stands for
the public key the private key can then
be packaged as a bundle which comprises
of values of p q G and X similarly the
public key can also be packaged as a
bundle having the values of p q G and Y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first
we can choose any random integer K which
falls under the bracket of 0 and Q to
calculate the first 16bit number of
assigning function of r we use the
formula G ^ K mod P into mod Q similarly
to calculate the value of the second
output that is s we use the following
formula that is shown on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having r and
s this bundle along with the plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bundle by passing it to the same
hash function we calculate the value of
w U1 and U2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula once calculated this
can be compared with the value of R if
the values match then the signature
verification is successful and our
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so
DSA is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the Simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
begin in is well known to optimize a lot
of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RSA algorithm needs a certain amount
of computational and storage space to
function efficiently this is not the
case with DSA which has been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royalty free a draft version of the
speculation fips 1865 indicates that DSA
will no longer be approved for digital
signature generation but it may be used
to verify signatures generated prior to
the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a public
key signature algorithm developed by Ron
reest ad Shamir and Leonard Edelman the
paper was first published in 1977 and
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment RSA can also encrypt and
decrypt general information to securely
exchange data along with handling
digital signature verification let us
understand how it achieve this we take
our plain text message M we pass it
through a hash function to generate the
digest H which is then encrypted using
the sender private key this is appended
to the original plane text message and
sent over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle we can pass the plane text
message with the same hash function to
generate a digest and the cipher text
can be decrypted using the public key of
the sender the remaining hashes are
compared if the values match then the
data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it receives the receiver's
public key to encrypt the data and uses
the receiver's private key in decrypting
the data thus there is no need to
exchange any keys in this scenario there
are two broad components when it comes
to RSA cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data the
second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plain text they use certain
variables and parameters all of which
are explained we first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as n
= p into q and compute the value of Zed
as P minus 1 into Q minus one a number e
is chosen at random satisfying the
following conditions and a number D is
also selected at random following the
formula Ed mod Z equal to 1 and it can
be calculated with the formula given
below the public key is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as Cal to m M to the^ e mod n and the
plain text can be calculated from the
cipher text as c^ D mod n when it comes
to a data encryption example let's take
p and Q as 7 and 13 the value of n can
be calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
needed to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91 1A 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated the formula c = m^ e mod n
which gives us 82 if somebody receives
this Cipher text they can calculate the
plain text using the formula C to the^ D
mod n which gives us the value of 10 as
selected as our PL
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receiver's public key so that you
don't have to share any secret key to
receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since they didn't
have the correct private keys to to decp
the information if a public key can deip
the information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be Amper proof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the usage of the keys the
private key won't be able to decp the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
Transit the cases of which are rather
low imagine creating an account on a new
website you provide your email address
and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in CLE
text format it is considered to be the
most unsafe option since anyone in the
company can read your password s a
single hack and a data server breach
will expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternative but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the pass passwords after
scrambling them completely but with no
way to decrypt them this is where
hashing comes to play since only the
hashed values are stored in the server
no encryption is needed with no plain
text passwords to protect your
credentials are safe from the website
administrators considering all the pros
hashed passwords are the industry
standard when it comes to storing
credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing works
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorithms that perform
mathematical operations on the main
plain text the value generated after
passing the pl text information through
the hash function is called the hash
value digest or in general just the hash
of the original data while this may
sound similar to encryption the major
difference says hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users password
words so how do they make use of these
hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers so the next time a user comes to
log to the account the password he
enters is passed through the same hash
function and compared to the hash stored
on the main server if the newly
calculated hash is the same as the one
stored on the website server the
password must have been correct because
according to has functions terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the sign up hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users's privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed under the
hash function we need to understand how
they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but more secure algorithms
are being used today like the Sha F of
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the respective algorithm
being used md5 has a digest of 128 bits
while s 256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted while some of them are easy
to guess others are placed in order to
preserve Security in the long
run the hash function must be quick
enough to encrypt large amounts of data
at a relatively fast piece but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being stored but what
if two different users are using the
same password since the hash function is
the same for all users both the digests
will be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risk are more common than one
would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashes without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the solt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the salt value will differ and so
will the digest there is a small problem
with this process though since the salt
is unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the the
server is hacked then the hashes will
need to be brute forced which takes a
lot of time but if they receive the
salts as well the entire process becomes
very fast this is something that
peppering aims to
solve peppering is the process of adding
a random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case
the pepper isn't stored on the servers
it is mostly hardcoded onto the website
source code since it's going to be the
same for all credentials this way even
if the servers get hacked they will not
have the right pepper needed to crack
into all the passwords many websites use
a combination of salting and peppering
to solve the problem of hash collision
and bolster security since BR Force
takes such a long time many hackers
avoid taking the effort the returns are
mostly not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy it's no surprise to see an
increasing interest in encryption
algorithms we have already covered the
major names like the dees and the AES
algorithm md5 algorithm was one of the
first hashing algorithms to take the
global stage as a successor to the md4
despite the secur vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 Still
Remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments the md5 hashing algorithm
is a one-way cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic check
sum to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up
plain text message to the md5 hash
functions which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 128bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the pl text the
goal of any message digest function is
to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value even a slight change in
the plane text should trigger a drastic
difference in the two digest this goes a
long way in preventing hash collisions
which take place when two different PL
Texs have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
Plaine text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed On To
The Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64 bit lens to be precise
are added to the message a final string
to be hashed is now a definite multiple
of
512 The Next Step would be to initialize
the message digest buffer the entire
hashing plane text is now broken down
into 512 bit blocks there are four
buffers or registers that are of 32 bits
each named a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed heximal
values as shown on the screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which differ with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements since
each 32bit subblock is run four times 16
such subblocks equal 64 constant values
needed for a single block iteration the
subblocks can be denoted by the alphabet
M and the constant values are denoted by
the alphabet T
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration at the very beginning
the values of buffers b c and d are
passed on to a nonlinear logarithmic
function the formula behind this
function changes by the particular round
being worked on as we shall see later in
this video Once the output is calculated
it is added to the raw value stored in
buffer a the output of this addition is
added to the particular 32-bit subblock
using which we are running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function that needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
array K since we have four different
elements in the array repeat since we
have 64 different elements in the array
we can use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the second
buffer of B of the output register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
a now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of ab c d
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512 bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output the formulas being used are shown
on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digest they don't consume
a noticeable amount of dis storage and
are compared comparatively easier to
remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
sizes of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit once the hash is matched file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't being tampered with
on route to the receiver of the
message we use our Wi-Fi everyday for
work and we use the internet for
entertainment and communication the
dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades a big portion of this
belongs to ensuring secure channels of
communication and data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the
NSA it was passed as a federal
information processing standard also
known as FS it has four different
families of hash functions ssj 0 is a
160 bit hash function published in 1993
and it was closed down later after an
undisclosed significant flaw sha1 is
also a 160 bit hash function which
resembles the earlier md5 algorithm this
was designed by the NSA to be a part of
the digital signature
algorithm sha2 is a family of two
similar hash functions with different
block sizes known as the sh 256 and the
Sha 512 they differ in the word size sha
256 uses 32 bits words where sha 512
uses 64bit words sh3 is a hash function
properly known as kak it was was chosen
in 2012 after a public competition among
non NSA designers it supports the same
hash lens as H2 and its internal
structure differs significantly from the
rest of the Sha family as we have
already iterated the process is
straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sh hash function which in
turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the pl text the goal of
any hash function is to produce digests
that appear to be random to be
considered cryptographically secure the
hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two Digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane texts
have the same
digest the S family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the digest let's go
through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2^ 64 bits in the case of
sha1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the plain
text compatible with the function and
the size needs to be in comparison area
to keep the digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the Sha 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
digest to bolster security but there
must be a definite balance between the
speed and security of a hash
function by Design all hash function of
the Sha 512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64 bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters this prepares our string to
have a length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits s the
message was 64bit short from becoming a
multiple of
512 now we add the length of bits in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is a perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plain text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each unlike other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 32 bits each they are named a
b c d and e these registers go through
multiple rounds of operation where the
first iteration has fixed hmal values as
can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512-bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each each of them goes through four
rounds of operation that use the entire
register and have the 512-bit block
along with the constant array out of
those four rounds each round has 20
iterations so in general we have 80
rounds sum
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration the formula can be AB CDE e
registor is equal to e plus a nonlinear
process P along with a circular shift of
a + WT + KT in this formula ABCD is the
register value of the chaining variables
as we discussed before p is a logical
process which has a different formula
for each round S5 is a circular shift by
five bits and WT is a 32bit string
derived from the existing subblock this
can be calculated depending on the
iteration at hand KT signifies a single
element of the 0 character element array
which changes depending on the
particular round at hand for the values
of WT the first 16 values are the same
as that of the subblocks so there is no
extra calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output next we use a
nonlinear process P that changes
depending on the round and uses the
values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
registor next the value of a is circular
shifted by five bits and is added with
the output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand root Force attacks depending
on the round the values are passed
through a logical operation which is
then added with the values of WT KT and
so on now that we understand how to get
our hash digest from the plain text let
us learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard sh 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this case
the plane text would be user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can monitor file corruption
by comparing hash values before and
after Transit once the hash is match
file Integrity checks are valid and data
corruption is avoided hash functions
will always give the same output for the
same input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also Al helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication they are
popular because their Theory makes
perfect sense to individuals and is
reasonably simple to implement for
developers on the other hand poorly
constructed passwords can pose security
flaws a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider toess access all of
the systems user accounts in this video
you will learn how to crack passwords
and simultaneously try to make your
passwords as Brute Force resistant as
possible let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being
cracked let's start by giving a basic
idea about password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources
malicious actors can engage in various
criminal activities with the information
obtained through password tracking the
procedure might entail comparing a set
of words to guess credentials or using
an algorithm to guess the password
repeatedly password cracking can be done
for several reasons but the most
malicious reason is in order to gain
unauthorized access to a computer
without the owner's awareness this
results in cyber crime such as stealing
passwords for the purpose of accessing
banking information other non-malicious
reasons for password cracking occur when
some has misplaced or forgotten a
password another example of
non-malicious password cracking may take
place if a system administrator is
conducting test on password strength as
a form of security test this enables so
that the hacker cannot easily access
protected systems the best way that
users can protect their passwords from
cracking is to ensure that they choose
strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong password should never be
ual words in addition strong passwords
are at least 8 characters long in many
password protected applications users
are notified of the strength of the
password they've chosen upon entering it
the user can then modify it and
strengthen the password based on the
indications of its strength now that we
understand the basics of password
cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employee tried and through tactics
to exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy even they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and a
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords da
today simply said this assault employs
the same terms that many individuals use
as passwords a hacker can compare the
password hash obtained to hashes of the
password dictionaries to find the
correct plain text password
now that the passwords have been hashed
the hackers attempt to achieve
authentication by breaking the password
hash they accomplish this by employing a
rainbow table which is a set of
pre-computed hashes of portable password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breaches are accomplished if the hash
matches in a bro Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run exhaustive
password combination in a substantially
shorter length of time with the growth
of hardware and technology in recent
years such programs have been
invigorated it won't be quick if your
password is more than a few characters
lengthy but it will eventually reveal
your password boot Force assaults can be
sped up by throwing more processing
resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to correct passwords
none of them are useful without the
right tools there are a prora of scripts
and Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash test let's go through
some of these
tools cane and able is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted password
using dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations recording scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of G enable the latest version is faster
and contains a lot of new features like
ARP poison routing which enables
sniffing on Switched Lance and man inth
middle attacks the sniffer in this
version can also analyze encrypted
protocols such as ssh1 and https while
containing filters to capture C
credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the river is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for unit-based
computers it was created to eval at
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
tracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre calculated
hashes creating this kind of dictionary
takes much more time than cracking a
single hash but after that you can use
the same dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force
methods with so many tools ready to enab
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect the
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and
passphrases have been demonstrated to
boost security significantly however it
is still critical to avoid lenier
passwords that have previously been
hacked or that feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as Hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names Etc if a hacker has access
to personal information about a specific
user for example via social media they
will test password combinations based on
that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or users
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't affect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while P
phrases serve the same objective the
length make them more difficult to break
in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass freezes however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two-factor authentication or
TFA can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone TFA does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification PIN and a code texted to
the user's smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit your information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have G in popularity and are
being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal information
let's start by learning about why strong
passwords have become an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords simple and commonly
used passwords enable Intruders to
easily gain access and control a
Computing device conversely a password
that is difficult to guess makes it
prohibitively difficult for common
hackers to break into a machine and will
force them to look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that one's computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion many individuals opt to tie
their websites to something they can
readily recall to generally easy
memorable combos however this does not
make the password unique in fact it's
the reverse passwords are handled by 53%
of individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for their
personal and job applications while this
may allow the user never to forget the
password it makes a single point of
failure the only pin to drop if one of
the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
Dons to understand how to create new
passwords for for accounts it is
recommended to keep the password length
at least 12 characters to ensure brute
forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make moving
over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force instant considering that are
already already algorithms present that
can counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for
hackers apart from using single
characters multiple times following
patterns that are present on the
traditional English keyboard such as ew
t y or the line below the main alphabet
such as the ZX cvbn M Etc make it easier
to guess since these are once again
common combinations that are present in
word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
it via social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how pass
freezes have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords a passphrase is a sentence--
likee string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while pass phrases can reach
up to 100 characters or more using a
long passphrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the many ways that users can
strengthen the security of their data
devices and accounts the longer a pass
phrase is the more likely a user is to
incorporate bits of entropy of factors
that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements aosr is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages ages that past phrases
have over common
passwords past phrases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier to
comprehend a line from your favorite
song or a quotation than a short but
difficult password passwords are
reasonably easy for humans and robots to
guess or crack online thieves have also
Advanced and created Cutting Edge
hacking tools to crack even the most
complex
passwords pass fre are nearly hard to
crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or
pre-compute these passwords complies
with password setting rules with e pass
phrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support past
phrases phrases of up to 127 k tors are
permitted on all major operating systems
including Windows Linux and Mac as a
result for optimal protection you can
use lengthier
passphrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass freezes this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one Place protected
by a single strong master password if
you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and ashleen have been
running for years now and are very
worthy recommendations if you want to
get started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already hacked or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most primary checkpoint to know
if our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown applications in the background
of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the
device next we also face problems
regarding passwords which are no longer
working or are changed without a user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our account
let's take a look at some more points
regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage
disk on the system which is unknown to
us
to better understand the points
regarding how to identify whether our
system is hacked or not let's take a
look then let's start with the first
point if we want to check whether our
system is hacked or not the first point
would be to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example apps and
browser control in my system it says
there's a problem with it which might be
due to hacking attempts that was done on
my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the issue according
to my antivirus software it says my
computer is at risk this might be due to
the interference from a cyber criminal
or a hacker while using different
illegal softwares during its hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of our system which we can
take a look using the task manager
software using the task manager we can
take a look at each and every
application that is being executed in
the system and see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files or folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker seems like there's a problem with
the username which means there was a
hacking attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing a web browser and
checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hiking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other Internet
Security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device data
and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
evolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain or
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp
in the year of 2020 the big news was
about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and his
phone being hacked by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that biz's mobile phone was
hacked by Saudi Arabian prints in the
year 2018 and gigabytes worth of data
was stolen from the device while there
are some issues being raised about the
report which states with the medium to
high confidence that Jeff pizos phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp uses endtoend encryption
to protect all communication on its
platform these encryption keys not only
make it impossible to decrypt messages
but they also prevent third parties and
even WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although end to
encryption makes WhatsApp more secure
than other communication apps no app is
100% safe to use like any application or
digital device WhatsApp is often
targeted by Bad actors it also has
access to your contacts and tracks where
and how long you use it putting your
privacy and personal information at
risk we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tiped to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp tofa using
SMS isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone bills are abnormally High or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well make sure you enable the option to
log the screen every time WhatsApp is
closed this will ensure no one else but
you can open your WhatsApp account just
head to the settings menu privacy and
select the screen lock option you will
then need to register your fingerprint
after the process is completed you will
have to scan your fingerprint every time
you open the WhatsApp app this adds an
extra layer of
security the two-step verification works
as an extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
twostep verification users have to enter
it periodically once it is activated
WhatsApp will sometimes keep asking
users to enter the six-digit passcode
users cannot disable this without
disabling the two-step verification
feature
altogether in case users do not provide
WhatsApp with an email ID and want to
disable twostep verification then the
number will be permitted to
reverifying messages upon reverifying
we often have the tendency to log into
to Whatsapp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
the Sait can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp before leaving
the office it just takes a few seconds
to log in again by just scanning the
code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to end encrypted
to verify that a chat is end to endend
encrypted open the chat tap on the name
of the contact to open the contact info
screen and then tap encryption to view
the QR code and a 60 digigit number
WhatsApp end to end encryption ensures
that only you and your contact can read
the message messages that are being
exchanged and nobody in between not even
WhatsApp with the necessary guidelines
out of the way let us go to the
recommended course of action should our
WhatsApp accounts be
compromised the first and most important
thing that you need to do is report the
issue to the WhatsApp support team for
assistance make sure that you reach out
to the support team through its help
desk and Report the hacking attempt
WhatsApp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve the issue via
email or within the app itself this will
help you to take prompt legal action
against the hackers if you can't access
your email call the support team in some
cases the support will deactivate your
WhatsApp account and request you to
reactivate within 30 days if you don't
want it to be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to to your
friends and family letting them know
that you've lost access to your account
this action prevents further
exploitation of your account and others
another reason you'll want to let your
contacts know you have no access to your
WhatsApp account is that they may fish
for personal information from your
banking number to your email address
hackers will cleverly attempt to gain as
much access to your personal information
as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security threat that hackers
can easily exploit to get into your
personal data over WhatsApp therefore it
is highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your WhatsApp Messenger has
been hacked go to your whatsa web and
tap or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a failsafe option
if you want to protect your personal
data at any cost possible you can always
open a new account later with the
security issues mitigated and before we
begin if you're someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or to become an ethical hacker
by graduating from the best universities
or a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply Larch
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schmith College of
computing the course link is mentioned
in the description box below that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered it's no secret
that the majority of our internet usage
is at the risk of being hacked be it via
unsafe messaging applications or
misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerab ability
assessment K Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers K
Linux has layers of features that we
will be covering in today's lesson let's
take a look at the topics to be covered
in this
video we start by learning about K Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of kinu
from the story of its origin to its
current
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Kali that make it an
attractive choice for penetration
testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start our journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general K Linux which is formerly known
as backtrack Linux is an open- Source
Linux distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
partion testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering color Linux is a multiple
platform solution accessible and freely
available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions khux takes its roots from
the Debian operating system Debian has
been a highly vendable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users
we did not get K Linux since the first
day how did it come into existence let's
take a look at some of its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
nopex as can be inferred from the name
name it was based on the noix operating
system as its underlying OS opix had
releases ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as wax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name Chang
was because the base OS was changed from
noix to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from WPIX there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being short to just auditor which
was once again using
noix its efforts were combined with wax
to produce backtrack backtrack was based
on slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this Ki
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of K Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct
features the latest version of Ki comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individuals
who are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
depositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
car Linux users worldwide a great deal
of damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that Khali's armm support would need
need to be as robust as they could
manage with fully working
installations K Linux is available on a
wide range of armm devices and has arm
repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing Journey the
first first way to use scal Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the Thum Drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavard that any change changes
made to the OS in this mode are not
written permanently some cases allow
persistent usage in live USBS but those
require further configuration than
normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hard
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this meth me is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the alloted
Ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install KY
Linux is by using a dual boot system to
put it in simple words the K Linux OS
will not be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run in into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is able
to run multiple operating systems on a
single host machine which in our case is
a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file you go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button we
can see we have a window archive which
will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMS side
of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later and some
operating systems we can use the ISO
file here directly and VMware will
install it for us but but for right now
in the case of K Linux the third option
is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has a a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution Kus is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the disc capacity this disc
capacity will be all the storage that
will be provided to your virtual machine
of K Linux think of your Windows device
if you have a 1 TB of hard drive you
have the entirety of the hard disk to
store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications for now we can
give around let's say 15 GB of
information or if a recommended size
foran is 20 we can just go ahead at 20
it depends all on the user case if
you're going to use it extensively you
can even go as high as 50 or 60 GB if
you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual dis as a
single file or storing them into
multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on
VMware sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this port ility
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out with the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine the
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will will
cause performance issues and the host
system if the memory has some amount of
free storage left let's say on idle
storage my Windows machine takes about 2
GB so I have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6 GB
it'll be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as
2GB of memory for the virtual machine
instance similarly we can use the number
of processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preet up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we're going to select
use ISO image file you're going to click
on
browse going to go to downloads and
select the IMO file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here so we're going to press enter on
that we going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this is be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is necess required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a land cable let's say if we
use the name
Kali domain name we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
you root accounts and the subsequent
below accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and set up lvm use entire
disc and set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more handson with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use the use entire dis guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on VMware we had set up a disc
capacity that we gave a purose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual dis on vmy it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's WR that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gp disc
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time it ask us
to select a network mirror we're going
to select as yes and move forward with
this next it's going to ask us for an
HTTP proxy which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the K Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the graub boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the gr loader on the same hard disk that
we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the grub bootloader is
being installed the grub is highly
essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order the absence of a
boot loader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file anymore since the
operating system is now installed onto
the virtual hard disk storage that we
had configured before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up
before and we have the Colo system
booted
up
and this is your homepage we can see the
installed applications over here which
are being used for penetration testing
by multiple security analysts
worldwide all of these come
pre-installed with K Linux and others
can be installed using the AP package
manager that we had
configured we can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment par security OS
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution more cater
towards penetration testers specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
for this
video we start by learning about what
par security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux of penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parro security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at the multiple ways that par
security OS can be installed be it on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parot security
is parat is a Debian based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
parro security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forensic
mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market with the basic introduction to
the operating system out of the way let
us have a look at the bare minimum
system requirements necessary to be able
to run this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual core CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
baros while multiple core systems will
provide more Optimum performance a small
beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variance of chipsets
be 32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly parat has no such requirements
and can be used with the leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS installed on
a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi settings these are just
some of the requirements for the
installation of parro security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a parro
security installation video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parot security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of militia's requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parat development
team will most likely add in it out
first before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parent security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the gal Linux
users all the tools you found in Kali
are present in parto and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating
systems however it's not all
productivity points for parro OS they
provide a choice between two different
desktop environments the made desktop
which comes pre-installed by default and
KDE for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use K Linux or paratos while
adding another desktop environment which
they find appealing while kalii has only
a single option parat has managed to
provide two optimized bills with M
desktop and KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parat os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes frequently less dis space and
computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality parat OS is also designed to
operate successfully of a USB stick but
Kali liux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine parat can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parad security OS will
override which whatever data the hard
disk already has now this is beneficial
if you want to preserve your data for
the long term but this might pose some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes you make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization
using virtualization software like
VMware or virtual box we can install
parad security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a Windows operating system in
case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parat sec.org
once we enter the the website move into
the download
section and select the get security
Edition over
here par security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environment serves as
a different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with a M
desktop we have two options either we
can go with the direct download or we
can get the torrent file for this
example if you press on the download
button and our download will start I
have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around 4 and 1/2 GB of space it will be
used to install this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded
we can close this and open VMware
Workstation VMware can also be used as a
player version or the Workstation
version if you have much more
familiarity with using virtual box of
virtualization application we can use
that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine oses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical
option moving on it'll ask us for a
source to where to install the operating
system from since we're going to use a
live ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press
next as we already know security is a
deban derivative so When selecting the
guest operating system type we're going
to go with Linux and the selection we're
going to choose whichever the highest
version of Debian is along with a 64-bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say parent security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard dis
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next for the dis size we're going to
specify how much of the current memory
are we going to allocate this is the
hard disk memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage we
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20 GB as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
disk as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended goto when installing for the
first time we click on next next here
and it's going to give us a summary of
the settings we have already settled
till now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parent security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10 machine when it
comes to the processors I'm going to
increase it to two and the number of CES
to two as well so giving out a total
four processor CES to the operating
system now this depends on what are your
computer rig and how much resources you
can justify so these need to be
customized according to the system at
hand hard size has already been set at
20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used physical drive and at Auto detect
we're going to use a use ISO image file
over here we're going to click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine at this point of time there are
two options we can go with the try
install option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot is so meanwhile VMware has an
prompt over here where it will try to
install some VMware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with a host
system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt
as you can see this is the live boot ISO
of the parat security operating
system currently it's running the mat
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website live boot ISO is necessary to
get a good feel of the operating system
there are many good Linux drosos that
have this live boot option so that you
can give a try of the operating system
before installing
permanently once you into the live board
we can start up with the installation
using the shortcut as you can see
install
parot going to double click
it and this is a calamaras installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to your Loc
and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard what people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-built provide the English US
keyboard so whatever ke keyboard you
choose make sure to type here and test
that all the buttons including the
superscript and the subscript buttons
are working correctly before moving
forward with this
step once you settled on the keyboard
that you need to install you can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're are going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20gb of storage we're going to
choose the that and we're going to erase
this
disk manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parad
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is already including
a Windows OS for now we're going to
select erase disk and press next we're
going to give our full name Let It Be
simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log in
this is your root password that we going
to give over here the root password of
this Cali Linux will act as the
administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing an updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next this is another summary of
the installation that we going to move
forward with have a look that whatever
changes we have made is according to
your requirements and once everything is
checked you can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parent security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here
disabled I'm going to click on
done we're going to shut down this live
boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down
we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the ISA image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click s over
here
this is the grub menu at this we G
different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options more often than not
we're going to choose the first option
and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see a username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here
and we're going to try a root password
and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword Pudo
a install and neof
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to
login going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided now that we have installed neof
fetch we can write the command neof
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can can see the OS name
as parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 megabytes which is supposed to
equal around 2 GB of RAM usage that we
had provided k Linux and parat Os are
two popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware
specifications today we will look at
both these distributions and settle on
the perfect choice for each type of user
let's go through the agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration Tes next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and Par security OS thereby making
a clear-cut conclusion on which OS is
perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formally known as
backtrack Linux is an open- Source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multi-platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux distrib
tions K Linux takes its roots from the
Debian operating system Debian has been
a highly dependable and a stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
Linux
desktop while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments
apart from boosting security it allows a
more profound element of security
control to the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at par
security operating
system pet security OS is a Dean based
Linux distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on the demian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux
kernel parot security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distribution that
can work under rigorous hardware and
software
specifications it features a distinct
forensic mode that does not Mount any of
the systems hard diss or partitions and
has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date
rolling release distribution such as par
security OS follows the same concept it
provides the most recent Linux kernel
and software versions as soon as they
become
available with a basic introduction to
the operator systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parro security
OS the latest version of K Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar functional
ity the K Linux team comprises a small
group of individuals who are the only
ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause scal Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that kali's
armm support would need to be as robust
as they could manage with fully working
installations kalii Linux is available
on a wide range of arm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts parad security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of
defense the configurations in the
operating system Act is the second
Gateway taking care of malicious
requests and dropping them off this is
particularly beneficial since should
there be a scenario where the latex
Linux kernel is causing some particular
issue the paratos development team will
most likely iron it out first before
passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reent enough parent security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Khali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
the main UI for a distribution being
highly modular in nature one can use
parent security OS while adding another
desktop environment that they find
appealing while K Linux has only a
single option par security has provided
two two optimized builds with M desktop
and KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over K Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratos is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine paratos
is more of a niche distribution if
you're searching for something lighter
than K
Linux features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user
for our first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ram required for
Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature Prime usage is a very
important facet while khux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
Fram
for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with par security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended dis
storage of minimum of 20 GB in Kali
Linux and minimum of 15 GB in parent
security so they can install all the
tools necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry parro
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing par security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
have has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux being a decade old penetration
testing distribution K Linux has formed
up a very big Community with strong
support signature par Security on the
other hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of K Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard Storage parro security
on the other hand was initially designed
to run off a USB drive directly thereby
requiring very minimal requirements from
a hardware perspective like just 320 MB
of RAM and no graphical acceleration
needed this means par security is much
more feasible for people who are not
able to devote massive resources to
either their virtual machine or on their
laptop hard disk
directly with the comparison done
between both of these operating systems
let's take a look at the type of users
both of these are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with
parro security if they want to go with a
very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
security desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking parent
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
with ethical hacking and penetration
testing becoming mainstream in corporate
environments train personnel and
relevant equipment are in high demand
the right software framework can be the
Tipping Point in a hacking Campaign
which deals with intricate Hardware one
such tool that has become a main stay
for decades is nmap when it comes to
scanning machines for open ports and
service
nmap has always been the first choice
for hackers being lightweight and open
source nmap has strong Community backing
and receives regular
updates let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about the
different phases in ethical hacking and
where nmap is most valuable to ethical
hackers we learn the basics of nmap and
its purpose during a penetration testing
campaign next we take a look at the top
level approach of nmap as a scanning
tool and and how it conducts these scans
on host
machines moving
on we cover the multiple modes and types
of scans that can be performed using
nmap on unsuspecting
users we also look at some Alternatives
that users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with
while a live demonstration of the powers
of nmap will help in shedding light on
the topics being taught
today let us first understand where and
why and map is
essential there are essentially five
phases in ethical hacking the
reconnaissance phase is the first phase
of the penetration test here the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
or passively or both it helps security
firms gather information about the
target system Network components active
machines Etc this activity can be
performed by using the information
publicly available and by using
different
tools the scanning phase is more tool
oriented rather than being performed
manually the tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using various
scanners such as war dialers port
scanners Network mappers and
vulnerability scanners the penetration
tester collects as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn to attack a Target in
a more sophisticated
manner in the gaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase the exploitation May be a
buffer overflow attack denial of service
attack session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools in the maintaining
access phase the penetration tester
tries to create a back door for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system while
allowing him to come back to the system
to retrieve more data further
on in the clearing tax phase the test
tester tries to remove all logs and
Footprints which might help the
administrator identify his presence this
helps the tester to think like a hacker
and perform corrective actions to
mitigate those
activities nmap is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system it is necessary
to know this before running the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage an insecure openings
and breach the device so the
reconnaissance and the scanning phase
are the points where nmap finds the most
use let us now understand what nmap is
from a Layman's
perspective nmap which stands for
network mapper is a free and open source
utility for network discovery and
security auditing many systems and
network administrators also find it
useful for tasks such as Network
inventory managing service upgrade
schedules and monitoring host and
service up time the program is most
commonly used via a command line
interface and is available for many
different operating systems such as
Linux free BSD and
gentu it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits nmap was developed for
Enterprise scale networks and can scan
through thousands of connected devices
however in recent years nmap is being
increasingly used by smaller companies
as well nmap uses raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what Services
these host are offering what operating
systems they are running what type of
packet filters and firewalls are in use
and dozens of other
characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single hor as well the rise
of the iot in particular now means that
networks used by these companies have
become more complex and therefore harder
to secure since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of worms
that leads to a thorough each of the
system the recent emergence of iot Bot
Nets like meai has also simulated
interest in N map not least because of
its ability to interrogate devices
connected via the UPnP protocol but also
to highlight any devices that may be
malicious now that we understand what
nmap is let us take a look at the
workflow of how an ethical hacker uses
this tool in penetration
testing at a practical level nmap is
used to provide detailed real-time
information on your networks and other
the devices connected to them we have
the hacker running nmap on a system with
a victim machine running a standard
installation of the operating system be
it Windows Mac OS or
Linux the nmap interface will send
specially crafted packets to generate
some reply from the victim machine the
victim machine in return will send some
information back to the nmap host with
replying some of the services and host
that are being run on the computers nmap
allows the network admins to find which
devices are running
discover some open ports and other
services this in turn help discover the
vulnerabilities and the possible entry
points for hackers to breach
into we are now aware of how nmap works
on a basic level but there are many
varieties of cans that users can run on
local machines let's take a look at some
of
them the Ping sweep is a simple type of
nmap scan where it pings to all the
available IP addresses to check which
IPS respond to ICM
protocol if the users need to know only
the number of IP addresses and not many
details the Ping sweep is very useful
it's fast and hence the results to be
known are fetched very
easily the SN scan is the most useful
type of end map scan which does work
very quietly it sends an SN packet via
the TCP protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available here the
acknowledgement pack is not sent back to
the system assuming that the connection
is not valid the scan is not shown in
most of the scan logs and hence it is
safe to use SN scan to identify the open
ports the TCP connect scan is similar to
SN scan in many aspects as it uses the
TCP layer to send packets and is passed
to all the ports here the difference is
that the full connection is done by
setting the acknowledgement packets back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more
accurate if all the accesses related to
the OS are available to the user it is
better to do a TCP scan than an S scan
as all the lowlevel and high level
accesses are required for the scan the
network is also loaded more and hence
users must be careful about overloading
the system and the
networks the idle scan is really used to
check whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular
Network users need not control the
external host but an IP address and a
port should be given to the same all of
requirements are taken from the scanner
itself the RPC scans or remote procedure
calls are done by hackers to make the
system vulnerable to virus attacks it is
thus necessary to know whether our
systems answer such calls and make our
system open to
malware RPC scan is done to check this
by finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by RPC
see the windows scan is a simple scan
where the application scans the
acknowledgement packets receiv received
from the PS Once the SN packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the AK
packets received the scan reports the
same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner the bounce scan is used to check
the security in the file transfer
protocol layer FTP layers mostly do not
accept any packets and once it is
rejected from the FTP layers there are
chances that it might be sent to an
internal layer so that it can access the
internal machines bounce can check this
loophole by doing exactly the same
process and identifies whether our FTP
layer is open to vulnerability or
not the F scan is similar to SN scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a tcpf packet if the system
sends an RSD packet it is a false alarm
and users need not be worried about the
same the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets or non responses null
scans are not useful for Windows as they
may not always produce the desired
results when it comes to looking at
Alternatives there's a wide range of
free network monitoring utilities as
well as free open- source vulnerability
scanners available to network
administrators and security
Auditors what makes nmap stand out as a
tool it and network security managers
need to to know is its flexibility and
power there are some alternatives to
nmap but most of them are focused on
providing specific Niche functionality
than the average system administrator
does need frequently M scan for instance
is much faster than nmap but provides
less detail in reality however nmap
provides all the functionality and speed
that the average user requires
especially when used along with other
similar tools like netc cap which can be
used to manage and control Network
traffic and Zen
which provides a graphical user
interface for nmap but as an allrounder
solution to network scanning nobody can
go wrong with nmap as their tool of
choice let's now take a tour of nmap
based on all the things we have covered
today in this live demonstration we
start by learning on how to install nmap
on a fresh operating system that doesn't
come pre-installed with the tool we also
cover them different types of scans that
can be run on local machines along with
checking multiple inferences on ethical
hacker can gather based on the scan
output of an nmap screen finally we run
scans on vulnerable machines to get an
idea of how to proceed with the outputs
We Gather using this tool if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more the
first step in our demonstration is
installing n map now it depends heavily
on what Linux distribution you're going
to use to perform ethical hacking
right now I'm using parot security
operating system if you're not aware of
what parot security is or even what K
Linux is we highly suggest that you
check out the videos of those two
operating systems on our YouTube channel
so that you can get a fair idea of what
they serve now if you are using any of
these two operating systems nmap should
come pre-installed by default to check
if nmap is pre-installed or not you can
just press on applications over here go
to the pentesting
section go to this information gathering
Tab and you should be able to see n map
right here now let's say you do not have
nmap pre-installed maybe you're using a
Linux distribution like Ubuntu or Linux
Min or something that is based on depan
operating systems one thing you have to
make sure that nmap should be in the
distribution repository once you check
that or even if you do not know if it is
present you can just disc command should
be Pudo which is to give root
permissions for installation a AP is the
package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Debian stable ubu Linux
Min K Linux par security and anything of
that
nature AP is the package manager which
handles the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install and
nmap press enter and it's going to ask
you for the root password that you set
when you install the operating system in
the first place enter your root password
and press enter again as you can see
it's saying that nmap is already install
the newest version since I'm running
parro security operating system now
should you be running this operating
system or even K Linux you should
receive a similar message and the
installation is already done if you are
using some other distribution let's say
even black o Arch Linux or Manjaro
anything like that the installation
steps will be slightly different this
Pudo AP install nmap command is for
distributions that are derived from
Debian and obano if you want to install
in Arch Linux based distributions you
have to use their package manager which
is known as
pamac but that is for a different step
and if you want to get an ethical
hacking the best way to start is by
learning e either K Linux or par
security now that the installation is
done we're going to learn how to use
nmap one of the most basic functions of
nmap is to identify active hosts on the
network we can do this by using a ping
scan the ping scan identifies all of the
IP addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to write end map the flag we're
going to to mention over here is sp now
these flags are the
different traits of the nmap scan
depending on what flag we use we can
send different kinds of requests to the
host that we are scanning now before
moving forward with this let me open
another terminal over here and check the
IP address we're going to write the
command if config and find the Subnet in
which this system is present as you can
see the IP address is 192.168 .
72131 now this operating system is being
run on a virtual machine software known
as VMware the VMware in itself is
running on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of par
security and the Windows operating
system which is the host system in my
scenario will fall in this particular
subnet so to run our scan we going to
Target
192.168 and
72.1
24 this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP
addresses this is going to be capital P
yeah if you spot any host or IP
addresses on that list that you cannot
account for you can then run further
commands to investigate them further as
of right now you can see the machine
that is the parro security this IP
address can be detected in the subnet
the
192.168 72.1 is my local Windows machine
that is running VMware software and
ultimately this virtual machine the 72.2
is the DHCP server that hosts the
internet connection of the par security
this we can ignore for now
now the Windows machine that we have
over here let's run some tests on that
going to clear a
terminal and we can close this
actually when scanning hosts and map
commands can use server names ipv4
addresses or IPv6 addresses a basic nmap
command will produce information about
the given host to run a basic port scan
we can just use n map along with the IP
now as you remember the IP is
192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my local
Windows 10
machine as you can see it shows the
ports that are open and the particular
servers that these ports are
running now you can also have a
detection of the operating system now
mind you this is not 100% correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions the flag that we going to
use is nmap minus
o along with the same IP
address like I said since this just TCP
IP finger printing it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the N
map
and Pudo
keyword going to repeat the same command
that we wrote
above as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows
10 with this Mac
address it has also shown the correct
build number of the Windows 10 system
that I am
using this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated now to get the necessary
information about these services for
example what versions they are using we
have a command known as SV which stand
for service version we use the same IP
address and press
enter
now as you can see the scan is complete
and if you can check the results of the
scan above here we don't see any version
number for the
services here we can actually check what
version they are running now this
becomes helpful when we are trying to
find specific versions to exploit for
example if VM a workstation 16. 1.2 had
some particular vulnerability we can
exploit it by checking this command
apart from the host scanning Port
scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well for
example I have already checked that the
443 command is open but I have found out
after running this lengthy scan let's
say I only want to check if command if
the port 443 is open and map I'm going
to use
the flag of minus P which stands for
port and give 443 as an argument here
using the same IP
address and you can see it says it's
open but we already knew it is open
let's say there was something else uh if
let's say we're going to scan if the
Apache web server port is open which
usually runs on
80 obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's
closed now we we can combine these two
commands by running both Bo
simultaneously to do that we can just
put a
comma and complete the rest
similarly expected it is closed and 443
is open another feature of n map for
Port scanning is showing of ranges now
ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example n map minus P we're going to
check what ports are open between 100 to
let's say
2,000 this acts as the
range everything else is the
same and it checks all ports in the
range of 100 to
2,00 whatever port is open in between
that range it it can be mentioned over
here we're going to clear the screen now
another flag that can be used with n map
is the SS command this runs a stealth
scan which is a little harder to detect
if you're the it admin of the system
that is being
scanned the results will more or less be
the same although this will need
elevated root
privileges
2.1
as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked style scans are relatively
tougher to check on much more intricate
systems this takes longer as
well now that we're done with both
scanning let's look at a vulnerable
machine the system that you're scanning
right now is this my own personal system
with everything is pretty locked down as
much as it can
be there is an attack box
running in the cloud the IP address of
which is over here now to be able to get
into this network we need to connect to
their personal network using a VPN so
what I'm going to do is switch to a
different workspace over here I'm going
to open open a
terminal and if you can see over here
there is a hack test. ovpn file I'm
going to connect to their VPN network
using this ovpn
file and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been established
like we discussed this is the vulnerable
device IP we're going to copy
this and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal we're going to
try to Ping this and check if we are
able to reach this
machine and as you can see we're getting
a reply back which means we are now part
of the local network where the
vulnerable machine is present
let's run a service scan map with the
respective
versions We ran the similar scan on my
local machine where we were able to
detect what version each service was
running what we're going to do over here
is by checking what kind of services are
open on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if in
map alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the machine
as you can see the scan is now
completed and we have some of the ports
that are being opened over here and what
kind of service they are
running now like we discussed this is
the first stage or sometimes even the
second stage of ethical
hacking what we can infer from here is
what are the services that are being run
now these two ports 139 and 445 are
actually Windows SM SMP server ports
which are above the windows Samba server
now every service has a particular put
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SM SMB
servers will function on these two
ports now SMB servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known
as of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the SMB server open it's
worth a shot that we try that exploit on
this
machine now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over
here and we're going to use Metasploit
for trying the exploit there we're going
to write Pudo msf console msf console is
the keyword first launching the
Metasploit
console enter the root password and wait
for met plit to
launch other than the ports we can also
see that it has checked the host name of
the system and the operating system as
well now that the Met SP is
open we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
Eternal blue
vulnerability we're going to write use
exploit blue and we're going to check
what kind of results we are getting over
here as you can
see serial number nine exploit Windows
SMB Ms 17010 Eternal blue it was first
disclosed in
2017 and SMB remote kernel pool
corruption let's say we're going to use
this particular exploit now all of this
may be confusing if you're not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part we're going
to use exploit number nine as we found
above to use exploit number nine
we're going to set a
payload which is our malicious code that
will run on the victim
machine now we're going to
check some options as you can see it has
by default pointed it to the 445 Port
since that is the port where SMB server
can be accessed
from
the parameter that's missing over here
is our host the r host is the IP address
of the vulnerable machine basically the
machine in which we want to attack now
I'm going to use the set
command to set the IP
address now if we
check we now
have a victim IP address
set another parameter that we can change
is the lhost this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you have
remember we had connected using a
VPN so we're going to be assigned a new
IP according to the VPN so if you write
if
config and check this one t0 is the VPN
adapter this is our IP address that we
have been assigned in the server in the
network where the vulnerable machine is
present so we're going to copy this IP
address we to move over this
workspace and we're going to set
lhost with that IP
address with that our options are set
now we're going to run
exploit and it's going to check if Samba
server vulnerability is
present as you can see it has written
that the target is vulnerable to this
particular exploit it's going to send
the malicious code and the malicious
code is set in the payload that you sent
above and we now have the shell command
of the Windows
machine as you can see C Windows system
32 to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write I ip config which is a
Windows only shell
command as you can see this is the IP
address that was assigned to the victim
victim
machine now while the major part of this
process was done on
Metasploit we would not have reached the
stage had we not found out that the 139
and 445 ports are open which basically
pointed us that we can try the Eternal
blue exploit of the windows Samba
servers similarly all the scans that we
run serve as a preface to the actual
stages or the actual hacking stages of
the
campaigns this SV command was necessary
because we could check what are the
exact services that are being running in
some cases if if it Apache server is
being run there are particular versions
which have particular exploits those
exploits will not work on other versions
so so we're going to have to check what
particular version is being run and
accordingly apply the exploit that can
be done either the Metasploit or you can
run some other tool but what exact
exploit we have to run and which
vulnerability we have to Target that is
why L map comes to help with the world
moving towards the next generation of
computer hardware the software side of
things still has a lot left to be
discovered with the majority of laptops
coming with Windows pre-installed many
users are devoid of the Linux operating
system experience which is more resource
friendly than the mainstream operating
systems it can be attributed to the
difficulty people used to face when
installing a new operating system like
Linux in the old days however a lot of
these issues are fixed nowadays thanks
to the big names like Debian and ubu who
have been instrumental in making Linux
based operating systems as user friendly
as possible but which one of them is
better for you let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today as we answer
this question for you
we start by learning about the operating
systems from a Layman's perspective and
uncovering the basic offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS caters
to so let's start by learning about
Ubuntu and Debian in
general ubu is an open- Source free
Linux distribution it is an operating
system for cloud computing in accordance
with support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canola
limited is responsible for the funding
of uban
basically ubu is released every 6 months
free support is available for 9 months
after every release and long-term
support which are the LTS is released
every 2 years the first release of ubu
was in October
2004 you must have heard about Ubuntu no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubuntu
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
one2 while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open-source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall feature set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never- Ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubu is gome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as no it integrates well with
common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for2 as well with unity as
its Flagship
environment Dean on the other hand is a
free operating system for your computer
which started in 1996 and is maintained
by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely free piece of software which
is started by Linus trowal and supported
by thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those tools are free as
well Debian is the mother of reux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-looking Dro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level disos are based
on Debian even ubu it is so stable and
feature Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their Dr based on Debian
rather than building it from scratch
Debian is run and maintained on its
GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and a holistic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and email minimalist window
managers you want to ships with unity
desktop by default but the package
manager can install The Gnome
environment if needed while also
including cinnamon lxd xfc KDE and M on
the other hand Debian gives you the
choice of choosing which desktop
environment you want from the Geto by
providing ISO files for each desktop
environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions ubu is the closest thing
to a household name among desktop Linux
distributions it is a great distribution
to start with and it's even a great
distribution to keep using after you're
more experienced if you're happy with it
it is user friendly in a lot of ways it
provides a simple desktop has an easy
installer and provides a checkbox during
the installation process that will
automatically install Flash plugins and
various codecs that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
Source or proprietary drivers that might
be necessary to get all your Hardware
working and easily install them for
you ubu is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canot Chronicle
is responsible for delivering six
monthly Milestone releases and regular
LTS releases from Enterprise production
use Enterprises can count on canonical
to support secure and manage Ubunto
infrastructure and devices with more
than 500 employees in over 39 countries
the company underpins the critical
infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of Ubuntu users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with uban
2 10.10 then it went on to be the
default desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gome however
it has made a comeback after uban to
18.04 while being completely stable the
H and Global menu hold up just fine with
major applications such as libary office
Thunderbird and other web browsers that
means that the unity desktop works as it
is supposed to while making you more
productive when some desktop
environments have a steep learning curve
Unity is very intuitive for new users in
spite of deviating from the traditional
start menu format that the windows users
are generally accustomed
to the calamaras installer is a
framework by design it is very
customizable in order to satisfy a wide
variety of needs and use cases calamaras
aims to be easy usable beautiful
pragmatic and more importantly
distribution agnostic Calamar includes
an advanced partitioning feature as well
which supports for both manual and
automated partitioning operations it is
the first installer with an automated
replace partition option which makes it
easy to reuse a partition over and over
for distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
d driven it is maintained and developed
by programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
in and take place and keep the project
going on it is completely free of
centralized control and this is also one
of the reasons for an undecided stable
release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it is where the latest
versions of programs are being
considered for inclusion in the deban
release cycle are uploaded and tested
because it has no official install media
and the few net boot images that are
built often don't work even people who
are willing to risk using a development
version may have trouble installing it
however it Still Remains the best place
to test new features that have not yet
made their way onto the stable
Branch Debian has only free and
open-source software in its repositories
this is mostly ample for users except
for users who use Hardware that only has
propriety drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have
propriety software if that is the
requirement Debian Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as their primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for the derivative one of which is also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to Ubuntu Ubuntu
has dropped the support for 32-bit
systems currently it supports only
64-bit devices and arm devices
installation is easy with the calaris
framework coming into ISO PR default and
the latest ISO can be downloaded from
the link being shown on the screen right
now in the case of dbn the support for
multiple range of devices is still
present that can also include 32-bit
systems and other smaller devices which
are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for new
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which we have
mentioned the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest ISO
depending on which desktop environment
you choose to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven open
source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
Ubuntu is also and free on open source
like Debian but it's backed up and
developed by a canonic which is a
corporate
company Debian and uban 2 are both
fundamentally fast regarding performance
as Dean comes bare minimum and is not
bundled or prepacked with additional
software and features it makes it super
fast and light rate at least when
compared with uban 2
directly both uban 2 and debn uses same
AP software packaging management system
but provide a different software
repository deban is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default you can always
install the paid versions but you have
to enable it manually UB to focuses on
usability including all the software
including free paid open source closed
Source Etc Ubunto also introduced a
universal package management system
called Snap it will be used across dros
and thus prevent more drro based
software
fragmentations as the dean drro does not
contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means Debian lack some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other paid software on the other hand
ubu does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible uban to also lets you
install and configure the necessary
drivers and firmware automatically
during installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before UB to support certain
proprietary packages as well which often
consist of graphic drivers which are
essential to gaming Debian focuses on
the open source aspect of the software
hence it can be a well-known fact that
with Gamers Ubunto and some other
distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both entu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to no experience and if they want
to have the latest versions of packages
and applications at all times on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customiz a desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
devices and their respective
drivers dbn on the other hand is cater
towards a little bit of experienced
users who can fix some minor bugs on
their own or with minimal Community
Support it also is for users who want to
support an open source approach rather
than an operating system which is devoid
of any contribution from other end and
is primarily backed by a corporation it
also doesn't favor gaming since it does
not guarantee compatibility with all the
newest graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards
in some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Debian is very useful for
people who are looking to run home
servers or even corporate environments
where running servers on Debian will
provide much more use data protection is
of Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they entrusted
with a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the Goodwill between the
organizations to prevent these malicious
attacks many automated security systems
have been developed but none of them
have been as used as IDs platforms which
are also known as intrusion detection
systems welcome to this introductory
lesson on intrusion detection systems so
let's go through the topics that we are
going to cover today we start with a
basic definition of ideas from a
Layman's perspective then moving on we
cover the multiple types of intruders
that seek to access confidential
information without any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of ideas systems that
can be used in corporate environments
today a small explanation of the two
types of protection is Then followed
when production to some of the most
well-known IDs tools on the market so
let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes in
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior an
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might inspect the data
carried by Network traffic to see if it
contains node malware or other malicious
content if it detects this type of
threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediate it once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the IDS doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data track
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however they do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete their objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any IDs fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an IDs cannot be a one-size fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
IDs analyst to tailor the ideas for the
interest and needs of a given site and
knowledgeable train system analyst ask
SC the trick with ideas is that you have
to know what the attack is to be able to
identify it the ideas has always had the
patient zero problem you have to have
found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
ideas response to the suspicious
activity by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
IDs is let us go through the different
types of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the idas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like dos
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use a system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approve than a masc creator
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as Misa misers are
people that are insiders and have direct
access to the system which they aim to
attack unethically by stealing data or
information
let us now go through some of the ways
the idas platforms can detect intrusion
before it is too late intrusion
detection systems primarily use two key
methods one is signature based intrusion
and the anomaly based intrusion
signature based intuition detection is
designed to detect possible threats by
comparing the given Network traffic and
log data to existing attack patterns
these patterns are called sequences and
could include bite sequence which is
also known as malicious instructions
sequences signature based detection
enables you to accurately detect and
identify possible loan attacks anomally
based intrusion detection is the
opposite it's designed to pinpoint
unknown attacks such as new malware and
adapt to them on the Fly using machine
learning machine learning techniques
enable an intrusion detection system to
create baselines of trustworthy activity
which is known as a trust model then
compare new behaviors to verify trust
models false alarms can occur when using
an an normally based ideas since
previously unknown yet legitimate
Network traffic could be falsely
identified as malicious activity now if
you combine both of those you have the
hybrid intrusion detection they use
signature based and anomaly based
intrusion detection to increase the
scope of your ideas this enables you to
identify as many threats as possible a
comprehensive intrusion detection system
can understand the evasion techniqu
cyber criminals use to trick and ideas
to thinking there isn't an attack taking
place these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
patent change evasion and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each method the first is a network based
idas the sensors are deployed at
strategic points within the network such
as within the DMZ or at the Network's
perameter the sensor can monitor
individual packets of inbound and
outbound traffic to and from all devices
on the network it analyzes them for
malicious activity and depending on the
network architecture and amount of
traffic involved multiple instances of
network based ideas may be necessary the
second category is host based intrusion
detection systems or
HS an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control list and the
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalis traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based ideas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a
cloud-based intrusion detection system
because of the internet facing nature of
the cloud on premises IDE Solutions are
not necessarily optimized for
monitoring for example network based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environments Network
perimeter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose-built cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of ideas deployment
tactics let us go through some tools
that excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer
environment the first tool being covered
is the solar wind security event
manager the solarin security event
manager is designed to integrate
real-time log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system this solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harmm it is also designed
to enact both signature based and anamal
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the maafe life Safe
macae Life safe is an intrusion
detection system designed to bring a
real-time threat awareness to your
physical and virtual networks it uses
signature based intrusion prevention and
anomaly based intrusion detection along
with emultion techniques to spot and
identify malicious activity maafe is
also built to correlate threat activity
with application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
cyber
attacks next we have bluma blera is a
security information and event
management platform built to enact
threat detection and responses across
your cloud and on premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your it infrastructure for suspicious
activity and configurations both of
which could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privilege information had been
a daunting task before the Advent of am
encompassing numerous apis single sign
on Frameworks and data handling policies
IM am has establish itself as a key
component of every it department but how
does it enforce these rules and who are
the key benefactors of these policies
what about the advantages of these
Frameworks and the workflow of these
systems we are here today to answer
these questions let's take a look at
some of the topics to be covered
today we start by learning about IM am
that is identity and access management
from a surface level so as to put a
clear idea of what it is next we cover
the general workflow and process of how
IM am works moving on we cover some of
the tools that find their place in an IM
am framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the I am learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations so let's get started by
learning about I am from a surface level
perspective identity and access
management or IM am is a set of
processes policies and tools for
defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to variety of cloud and on
premise applications the users can
include customers Partners employees
devices like computers smartphones
routers Etc the core objective of IM
systems is one digital identity per
individual or item once the digital
identity has been established it must be
maintained modified and monitored
throughout each users or devices access
life cycle access and user are two vital
IM IM Concepts access refers to the
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file users could be
employees Partners suppliers contractors
or even customers furthermore employees
can be further segmented based on their
roles IM systems are designed to perform
three key tasks identify authenticate
and authorize meaning that only the
right person should have access to
computers Hardware software apps any it
resources
Etc the for the entry of new users or
the changing of the roles of existing
users the list of access privileges must
be up to date all the time I am
functions usually fall under it
departments or section that handle cyber
security and data
management now that we understand the
importance of I am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principle is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principle it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by mul
multiple authentication factors and
Googs among other things once the
identity is confirmed the principal has
the ability to view the data behind the
wall of security and take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular buket of organization
by changing the data the
information when it comes to
authorization it carries out the rest of
an organization identity and access
management processes once the user has
been authenticated users are granted
authorizations according to the role at
an organization the practice is referred
to as role based access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it well
authentication is fully straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single signon
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organization
ations SSO helps in collecting valuable
insights about user behavior and
preferences since it attacks them as
they move from one application to
another connected by one single
login next is multiactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect
your organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in business to
Consumer scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
friction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heighten scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce you may
want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished through setup
authentication or adaptive
Authentication in which users only
trigger MFA if they're trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there are multiple ways IM
IM systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks by monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine use of a breached
password use of devices and IP addresses
with a poor reputation among other
things these are some of the most widely
used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks
you can use IM to identify policy
violations or remove inappropriate
access privileges without having to
search through multiple distributed
systems we can also leverage IM IM to
ensure that security measures are in
place to meet Regulatory and auditing
requirements IM IM provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to to user
authentication Privileges and validation
and attend to the privilege crep
problems IM IM simplifies signup and
user management processes for
application owners end users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and promotes
user
satisfaction IM Services can also lower
operating costs using Federated identity
Services means you no longer need local
identities for external users this makes
application Administration easier
cloud-based IM Services can reduce the
need to buy and maintain on premise
infrastructure so importance of a cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into manag or
Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cred uh certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
uh in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish their routing uh the pathing
of how data packets will travel across
the network this certification covers
all the basic concepts that you require
to understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply uh you can study
for this you can undergo a training and
then you can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously is
Cisco so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of question questions that you
going to get is multiple choice
questions where you have a question and
four answers and you have to choose the
correct answers among those drag and
drop where you have to click on an
object and drag it to its appropriate
Place probably a architectural diagram
and you have to let's say pick on a
router and place it into a particular uh
position if you place it correctly you
answer the answer the question correctly
otherwise it's wrong and a simulator
where you where there could be a
configuration you need to configure it
in a particular Manner and then check
whether the configuration is correct or
not the pass Mark is around 800 to 850
out of a possible, marks so each
question will have a different weightage
depending on the depth of the question
depending on the difficult level of the
question or the difficulty level of the
question which uh would then count
towards your marks and if you score 800
to 850 that's when you clear the exam
the job roles as we have discussed over
here would be more more on the network
administrator side or a network engineer
side depending on the level of
experience that you you have the
salaries uh that are expected from this
job roles in the US are around $55,000
to $90,000 annually the next one is the
comcha certification called Security
Plus comcha is also a global
certification Authority for uh infosec
courses so this certification teaches
candidates on how to secure applications
networks and devices it focuses on
Hands-On practical skills in the field
of network security I have trained
people on this certification myself so
uh I know this certification is quite
handson it deals with the concepts to
the core it helps you understand the
concepts and then in the Practical
Hands-On demo uh you need to execute the
Practical yourself so that uh you can
gain that knowledge the recommended
level for a candidate to attempt this
training would be at least around 2
years of experience in the it sector in
addition if you have already been
certified for Network plus certification
from comia which is the Baseline
networking certification this is also a
preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate Prov provider and the exam
fees for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can be
a little bit confusing can be a little
bit lengthy so you will require all
those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance-based the pass Mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security Engineers position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this uh person
would be around
$72,000 then comes the CH or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC counil now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hacker perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
four hours and you will only get
multiple choice questions in here now
for CH there are two exams one is the
multiple choice questions and the second
is a practical exam where uh you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
IAB scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CH practical the cut off
varies from 65 to 85% depending on the
questions that you have answered and the
weightage associated with each and every
question as said the job roles would be
as a penetration tester or security
engineer and your salaries would start
from around $90,000 annually then comes
the CND or the certified Network
Defender also from EC Council now this
is more on the network defense site so
here again the job rules would be where
you uh where there's a network that you
have and you're going to try to secure
the network and the communications that
are going to travel over the network so
you need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or as uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those Networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for this certification is $350 US
the exam the exam is of 100 questions to
be answered in 4 hours again it's just a
multiple choice questions so you get a
question with four options you answer
the correct one and you move on to the
next question the pass percentage again
varies from 60 to 85% depending on the
questions answered and the weightage of
that question job roles to be applied
Network defense technician CN analyst or
a security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from
$65,000 to $75,000 per anom then comes
the forensic investigator course which
is exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is s after mainly in the
law enforcement areas but there are a
few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigation
the certification provider for this is
also AC Council and the exam fees are
$500 this is an advanced level
certification so uh understanding of
applications networks and operating
systems is a must before you attempt
this the exam is quite similar 150
questions in 4 hours again it's just a
multiple choice question exam the cut
off again is from 60% to 85% depending
on the questions and the weightage of
each and every question job rules it
security specialist network security pro
the job rule rols foreign sake
investigators law enforcement agencies
security Specialists homeland security
jobs and your salaries would be around
$888,000 and above all right now let's
talk about the managerial level
certifications kit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate an in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kit is
all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certifications so around 8 years of
manager experience is suggested before
you attempt the coid 5 certification to
understand all the aspects and to help
you implement the framework properly the
certification certificate provider is
isaka the exam fees around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50%
the job roles associated with this
certification would be to uh when you
apply for a information security manager
or as a security consultant or a cyber
security manager and your roles and
responsibilities would be to govern the
uh it space that the organization owns
so all the servers desktops the network
the data flows the databases everything
and how it needs to be managed and how
it needs to be governed in a secure
manner annual salaries would be around
$100,000 Plus
then the cism also called as sism it
stands for certified information
security manager and as the name
suggests it's a security manager
certification it helps the candidate in
understanding the relationship between
business goals and information security
so now you're going into the space where
you're not only technical in nature but
you also have to understand the business
needs the goals of the business and you
have to align the information security
of your infrastructure along with the
business needs and the business goals so
it is your inputs that are going to go
to the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any
fine-tuning around 5 years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification
again providing by isaka and the exam
fees for isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in 4 hours uh quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be uh scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your your job profiles would be either a
risk manager or a risk consultant
analyzing the business requirements to
the infrastructure security that uh that
you have and to identify if there any
risks associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $88,000 and above then the cesa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
5 years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where you're
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that
everything is in place you're compliant
with let's say uh ISO 2701 guidelines or
the policies that you have created
yourself and everything is working in
order so it's more of a checklist where
you're going to just check everything is
in place and you're conforming to
standards this certification is also
provided by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanisms should be in place
pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your job
roles would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field field of is
controls that means information security
controls you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risk and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is isaka 5
$75 for isaka members $760 for non isaka
members for the exam fees a similar
question 150 questions to be answered in
4 hours multiple choice based on
performances so they may give you a
scenario where you have to perform a
risk analysis and provide a report and a
solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to
certain certain how the organization is
going to be affected and then you will
also be looking at compliances as far as
these job roles are concerned average
annual salary would be 119,000 and above
moving on to advanced level
certification now this is where we come
across the cissp or the cisp
certification certified information
system security professional this is the
gold standard of all certifications if
you have this certificate it's you can
basically be assured of a job in the IT
world now just to qualify you'll have to
have 5 years of experience in the
information uh security field there are
eight domains that are specified by
cissp and you have to prove that you
have knowledge and you have work
experience of around 5 years in at least
two of those domains if you do not have
those kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
you get six years to accomplish the 5
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification before taking up the
cisp certification it is suggested that
the candidate clears all the
intermediate level certifications not
all but some of them in fact I've seen
people do the other way around they
qualify for cissp they give the exam
once your cisp the cisa or cesm CIS or
cism exams are way easier to crack but
you need to have that kind of experience
I have seen people with 15 years of
experience and more fail at this
certification in the first attempt the
certificate provided is IC Square the
exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after this that you
might want to do the questions now the
exam has changed if it is the English
version that you're giving it's 150
questions to be answered in 3 hours if
it is the non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6- hour exam exam you
need to plan it really well it sounds
really easy but the questions are quite
tough they're scenario based and the
answers are quite confusing as well you
would get multiple choice questions you
would get drag and drop and you might
get simulators as well uh the pass Mark
is 700 out of 1,000 but each question
has a different weightage so uh it
depends on which questions are asked of
you and which questions you've answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$118,000 for this certification and if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security that
is by graduating from the best
universities or a professional while
sits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply Larch
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from the MIT schwarzman
College of Engineering and the course
link is mentioned in the description box
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
and before we begin if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Larch postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of computing the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered in today's interconnected
world the significance of cyber security
has reached Paramount levels as
technology continues to advance at an
unprecedent pace so do the risk and
threats lurking in the digital landscape
recently in April 2023 the shields
Healthcare Group a medical service
provider located in Massachusetts
experienced the most significant data
breach towards the end of the month
report surfaced revealing that an
individual involved in cyber crime had
illicitly access the organization
systems and successfully obtain the
personal information of approximately
2.3 million individuals organizations
and individuals alike are realizing the
critical need for qualified
professionals who possesses the skills
to defend against cyber attacks one such
certification that has gained widespread
recognition is the certified ethical
hacker or C certification so in this
video on step-by-step guide to crack C
exam we will be covering various topics
like why C what is C exam eligibility
criteria for C and how to prepare for C
exam also make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn now before moving forward let me
ask you a quick question so which of the
following terms describes an individual
who gains unauthorized access to
computer systems with malicious intent
option A is white hat hacker option b is
black hat hacker option C is gray hat
hacker and option D is script Kitty now
you can pause this video and answer in
the comment section below now let's
start with the first topic which is y c
or certified ethical hacker so there is
a high demand for cyber security experts
in various businesses to hire these
experts organizations have certain
requirements these profession need to
have a good understanding of security
Concepts and be familiar with the latest
tools processes and Frameworks to stay
ahead of cyber criminals and prevent
data Brides certifications like C or
certified ethical hacker offered by EC
Council play a significant role in this
scenario the C programming is designed
to train ethical hackers comprehensively
covering the latest hacking Trends and
introducing professionals to technology
that help prevent data breaches this
certification is recognized globally
meaning your skills and knowledge will
be valued by organizations around the
world regardless of your location the
course instructs participants on
practical strategies that can be used in
real life situations and future careers
the CH exam focuses on understanding how
malicious individuals exploit weaknesses
in addition to offering promising job
prospects the C certification training
provides a wealth of knowledge that is
not easily obtained through other
information security courses so if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
then try giving a shot at simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schatzman College
of Engineering the link is in the
description box that will navigate to
the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered also have a look at what our
Learners has to say about the course hi
I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old and last
year I skill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the it sector
and various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled and certified instructors
with many companies before a security
analyst and architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got got with the job I just started
with infosis as a cyber security
consultant happened on first now let us
understand about this certified ethical
hacker or C exam so the C exam focuses
on theoretical understanding and does
not involve hacking actual systems it
emphasizes comprehension of hacking
Concepts tools and methodologies however
to obtain the C Masters designation you
must also pass a six hour practical exam
with 20 challenges this exams evaluates
your practical application of Knowledge
and Skills in real life scenarios but
that's a choice if you want to apply for
Masters so the CH exam is 4 hours long
the exam consists of 125 multiple choice
questions the passing score required for
certification where is depending on the
specific exam some exams state in
passing score as a percentage While
others base it on the difficulty of
questions and the knowledge or skills
needed to demonstrate competence in the
subject the actual cut score determined
by subject matter experts depends on the
difficulty of the questions and ensures
fairness in evaluation skills if you
encounter more challenging questions
fewer correct answers are needed to pass
while an easier set of questions
requires higher percentage of correct
answers thus performance relative to the
passing standard can be higher even with
fewer correct answers in a difficult
question set so now let's have a look at
the sections so the sections covered in
the program includes section number one
that is background then there is section
number two which is analysis of or
assessment then there is section number
three security then comes section number
four tools systems and programs section
five is procedures and methodology
section six is regulation and policy
section seven is ethics so this was
about the C exam now let's have a look
at its eligibility criteria so the
eligibility criteria for C exam before
you start preparing for CH exam it's
important to meet certain requirements
firstly you must show this EC Council
that you have at least 2 years of
experience in information security and a
specialization in that field through
your educational background additionally
keep in mind that the CH exam has a cost
of
$100 and make sure you fulfill these
criteria before moving forward to avoid
wasting your time so this was about the
eligibility criteria for C exam now
let's understand how to prepare for CH
exam so the first step in preparing for
C exam is joining a forum so so there
are many online forums and blogs
dedicated to C where people with similar
interest and goals gather these forums
are filled with individuals who are
either preparing for CH exam or have
already taken it they share valuable
tips strategies and general advice based
on their experiences by participating in
these forums you can interact with other
C students and professionals this allows
you to exchange knowledge and discover
each other's strengths and weaknesses
it's a great way to identify areas where
you may need to improve your
understanding remember what one person
is good at another person may struggle
with through discussions on the Forum
you can learn from others and reinforce
your own knowledge through repetition
which helps with better retention the
second thing you can do is create
important topics checklist so once you
have identify the areas where you lack
knowledge as a hacker it's important to
make a checklist of study topics
prioritize the topics that need more
attention don't forget to allocate some
study time to the topics you already
know it's always beneficial to reinforce
and refresh your existing knowledge
however the main focus should be on
addressing the knowledge gaps First Once
you have addressed those gaps you can
revisit the other topics later along
with this you can also take up EC
council certification assessment EC
council certification assessments refers
to the international evaluation process
conducted by the international Council
of electronic Commerce Consultants the
certification assessment typically
involves an examination that accesses
the candidates understanding of the
relevant Concepts tools and best
practices in their chosen certification
track the exam is educational and the
questions are beneficial for studying
purposes using the training platform the
candidate can access the levels of
Readiness and analyze their preparedness
for the exam along with taking self
assessment you can also take help from
study guides while we emphasize the
importance of not relying solely in
books it cannot be denied that books
hold a wealth of knowledge when
preparing for the CH exam it is a
essential to thoroughly read the
recommended books this approach will
addresses all your what and why
questions regarding cyber security and
ethical haging the content provided in
these books is of top quality offering
precise definitions descriptions and
diagrams for almost every topic we
suggest dedicating at least 1 hour daily
to study in order to grasp all the
concepts covered in the training so by
understanding the exam objectives
setting up study plan utilizing quality
resources and reviewing your weak areas
you are well equipped for success
remember to stay focused manage your
time effectively and maintain a positive
mindset throughout your preparation with
dedication and perseverance you can
confidently approach the CH exam and
achieve your certification goals hello
and welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in today's video we will be
discussing the Intriguing world of
ethical hacking with the rise of cyber
threats and the increasing need for
robust cyber security ethical hackers
have become an integral part of the
modern digital landscape in this video
we will explore what ethical hacking is
is why ethical hacking are in high
demand salary Trends in the field of
ethical hacking skills required for a
career in ethical hacking and tips for
starting a successful career as an
ethical hacker at the end of this video
we will be sharing some useful tips so
keep watching till the end of this video
so let's dive in before moving forward
let me ask you a quick question so what
is the main goal of an ethical hacker
option A is to hack into systems and
steal sensitive informations option b is
to test and identify vulnerabilities in
systems and networks option C is to
create new security threats and exploits
option D is to cause harm and damage to
the Target organization now you can
pause the video and answer in the
comment section below so let's start
with the first topic that is what is
ethical hacking ethical hacking also
known as whad hacking is the practice of
intentionally probing computer systems
networks or applications to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the main
difference between ethical hackers and
malicious hackers is the intent and
legality of their actions ethical
hackers operate with the permission of
the system honor and their goal is to
identify vulnerabilities before they can
be exploited by malicious hackers they
use their skills and knowledge to help
organization strengthen their cyber
security defenses and protect sensitive
data from unauthorized access as
Reliance on technology and the internet
continues to grow so does the risk of
cyber threats organizations both large
and small are constantly seeking ways to
secure their digital assets and
Safeguard their business operations
their demand has led to a significant
need for skilled ethical hackers who can
proactively identify and fix
vulnerabilities in systems ethical
hackers play a crucial role in helping
organization prevent data breaches
protect customer information maintain
compliance with industry regulations and
Safeguard their reputation with the
increasing awareness of cyber security
threats ethical hackers are in high
demand across various Industries
including Finance healthc care
technology and government sectors now
let's discuss some salid trends for
ethical hackers the rising demand for
for cyber security expertise has led to
a significant need for ethical hackers
consequently skilled Professionals in
the field have experienced favorable
salary Trends in recent years several
factors impact the salaries of ethical
hackers including their experience
certifications industry and region the
roles that fall under the umbrella of an
ethical hacker may include penetration
tester penetration tester also known as
pentester if you're interested in
pursuing a career as a penetration
tester you will need to develop a strong
skill set in various technical areas
including cluding programming operating
system networking and cyber security
principles pent testers are responsible
for conducting authorized tests on
computer systems networks and
applications to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses and provide
recommendation for improving security
with an average salary of 5 lakhs per
year in India and $12,000 in the United
States becoming a penetration tester can
be productive care your choice simply
learns professional certificate program
in ethical hacking and penetration
testing is designed to equip you with
the necessary skills to analyze the
threat landscape and develop strategies
to ensure the stability and security of
systems through Hands-On training in
real world cases you will Master
essential cyber security skills in just
6 months you will learn the advanced
cyber security strategies that will
enable you to protect networks and data
from breaches next is vulnerability
accessor this role involves identifying
and accessing potential vulnerabilities
in computer systems networks and
applications using various tools and
techniques to determine the level of
risk associated with those
vulnerabilities the average salary of a
vulnerability accessor is 950,000 in
India and $61,000 in the United States
next up we have information security
analyst an information security analyst
is a professional responsible for
protecting an organization information
assets including Data Systems Network
and applications from potential security
breaches and cyber threats information
security analyst play a critical role in
safeguarding sensitive information and
ensuring the confidentiality integrity
and availability of data the average
salary of an information security
analyst is 6 lakhs per year in India and
$99,000 per year in the United States
the Caltech cyber security boot camp is
designed to help you develop the skills
needed for this Ru this comprehensive
course curriculum covers defensive and
funship cyber security digital forensics
penetration testing infrastructure
design and much more you'll have have
the access to labs and assisted
practices that expose you to several in
demand cyber security tools allowing you
to gain practical hands and experience
in a supportive learning environment
security analyst this role involves
monitoring and analyzing computer
systems networks and applications for
security incidents and breaches and
taking appropriate actions to respond to
and mitigate these incidents the average
salary of an information security
analyst is 6 lakhs per year in India and
999,000 per year in the United United
States now let's discuss skills required
for a career in ethical hacking a
successful career in ethical hacking
requires strong foundation in cyber
security and a diverse skill set some of
the key skills that aspiring ethical
hackers should possess include
Proficiency in programming language such
as python C++ and Java understanding of
networking Concepts like protocols
knowledge of operating systems and
databases expertise in tools and
Technologies used in ethical hacking
such as metas sploit wi shark and nmap
and familiarity with cyber security
Frameworks and best practices
additionally ethical hackers should have
excellent problem solving skills
critical thinking abilities attention to
detail and the ability to work
independent or as a part of the team
continuous learning and staying updated
with the latest developments in cyber
security is also a crucial for
successful career in ethical hacking now
let's have a look at some tips starting
a career as an ethical hacker can be
exciting and rewarding here are some
tips to help you k start your journey
first is demonstrate an ethical hacker
mindset develop curiosity problem
solving and continuous learning mindset
to excel in the field of ethical hacking
second is obtain relevant certifications
certifications like C CCH cyber security
boot camp oscp and advanced executive
programming cyber security these
certifications add credibility and
demonstrate expertise these
certifications will help you in securing
a nice job in the market third is build
practical experience practice ethical
hacking in a controlled environment such
as setting up your own lab or practicing
in CTF competitions to gain hands-on
experience Real World experience will
help you develop practical skills and
insights into different types of systems
networks and applications next is stay
updated with the latest threats and
Technology cyber security landscape is a
constantly evolving and it's a crucial
to stay updated with the latest threats
vulnerabilities and Technologies follow
industry blogs forums and news sources
practice in online communities and
attend conferences and workshops through
to stay informed and continuously
improve your skills welcome to a world
of ethical exploration in India a realm
of topn ethical courses awaits you these
courses not only equip you with
essential skills but also guide you in
making responsible choices so let's
embark on a journey to discover the top
five ethical courses in India where
learning meets consigns in the most
accessible and engaging way possible but
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so what is the primary
objective of ethical hacker option A is
to steal sensitive information option b
is to comprise computer systems option C
is to identify vulnerabilities option D
to spread virus now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below now let's start with the first
course on the list which is postgraduate
program in cyber security so this
comprehensive course equips you with the
skills to safeguard your system and data
effectively from risk assessment to
compliance you'll gain solid foundation
in cyber security this course is offered
by simply learn this program offers a
range of courses spanning from
fundamental to Advanced levels and
include prestigious industry
certifications key highlights of this
program includes simply learns
postgraduate certification upon
completion exclusive Master Class hosted
by MIT modules curated in collaboration
with MIT secc and EC Council real world
cyber security case studies from various
Industries access to C kit for Hands-On
practice engage in 25 plus practical
projects to enhance your skills then
there is accumulate your learning with a
Capstone project across three domains
then you can also become a part of MIT
csil professional program community so
these were the key highlights of this
program other than this you will be
delve into a diverse area of skills
including Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
ideas f firewalls Security Management
cryptography and more so if you are
really interested to become a cyber
security expert then this course is for
you enrolling this program is really
easy apply online start by completing
the userfriendly online application form
share your details and intent to join
the cyber security certification program
second is selection our admission panel
will review the applications and short
list candidates based on their
qualifications and aspirations then
third is confirmation if you're among
the chosen candidates you'll receive an
offer of admission secure your support
by paying the program fee so this is how
you can enroll in this program so this
was about post-graduate program in cyber
security by simply learn now let's move
on to the next program which is cyber
security expert Masters program by
simply learn simply learn cyber security
expert Masters program is designed to
help cyber Security Professionals to
develop skills at different levels that
is foundational intermediate and
advanced these skills are backed by top
certifications like
C cism cissp and ccsp Etc the program
kicks off with basic technology training
and then moves to more advanced topics
like reverse engineering and network
penetrating testing Etc by completing
this course you will be able to first of
all stay updated keep yourself informed
about the latest cyber security Trends
learn how to implement effective
security measures using suitable
hardware and software for your
organization second would be defend
against fishing learn ethical security
practices to protect against fishing
attacks and other risks then third is
Embrace cloud computing understand the
importance of cloud computing for your
business and how to use it for Success
then there is ensure compliance get
familiar with legal requirements privacy
policies and auditing process for your
Cloud environment then after that there
is optimize it infrastructure streamline
your it setup and invest in right
software solutions for a well organized
infrastructure partner with experts who
have your best interest in Mind by the
time you complete this master's program
you will become skilled in handling
Advanced hacking Concepts which will
help you manage information security
effectively upon completion you'll be
able to safeguard the moment of data
perform actions of recovering from
disasters manage security for client
databases and handle security aspects
related to cloud service providers and
many more things like that upon
completion of this master's program you
will receive the certificates from
Simply learns in cyber security course
es in the learning path this certificate
will testify to your skills as an expert
in cyber security upon program
completion you will also receive an
industry recognized Master's certificate
from Simply learn so this was about
cyber security expert Masters program
now move on to the next program which is
Advanced executive program in cyber
security this Advanced executive program
in cyber security will help you develop
expertise in defensive cyber security
application security malare analysis
ethical hacking Etc in partnership with
triple it Bangalore and npci this
program is tailored to empower you with
the skills in defensive cyber security
ethical hacking malware analysis and
more by completing this program you earn
a prestigious certificate from triple it
Bangalore Shing your accomplishment
engage in enlighting master classes led
by trop triple it Bangalore faculty
gaining insights from their wealth of
knowledge moreover receive a virtual
internship certificate from npci and
reaching your practical experience the
course is designed for Hands-On learning
featuring over 30 demos and multiple
projects conducted in integrated Labs
with lifetime access to self-based
videos you can learn at your convenience
a valuable triple it bang transcript
validates your skills in ethical hacking
penetration testing cryptography
ransomware analysis malware analysis
Enterprise security network Concepts and
threat hunting this program is your
gateway for a promising future in the
dynamic realm of cyber security the
admission process for this Advanced
executive program in cyber security
consists of three easy steps interested
candidates will need to apply by
submitting the application from online
candidates will be shortlisted by an
admission panel for this PG in cyber
security based on the application
submitted then selected candidates will
be awarded an offer of admission that
they can accept by paying the program
fee upon completion you will get the
final program completion certificate
from Simply learn individual course
completion certificate for all the
courses in the learning path from Simply
learn then there is executive program
certification from MIT certified ethical
hacker certificate from EC Council MIT
then there is professional program
Community membership also you'll get so
these all the things you'll get in this
Advanced executive program in cyber
security all right now let's move on to
the next best course which is
professional certificate program in
cyber security this professional
certificate program in cyber security
offered by IIT kpur in collaboration
with simply learn equips participants
with expertise to access the threat
landscape and device strategies for
ballst string system security and
stability this program facilitates the
Mastery of vital cyber security
proficiencies through immersive Hands-On
training embedded in real world
scenarios completion of this program
Awards a certification from IID kpur and
simply learn candidates will gain
exclusive access to enlightening master
classes hosted by esteemed I kpur
faculty the curriculum culminates in a
practical Capstone project that engages
participants in Industry relevant use
cases fostering hands-on experience
simply learn learning management system
that is LMS provides seamless access to
integrated Labs enhancing practical
understanding the program
comprehensively covers essential skills
including ethical hacking cryptography
Concepts ideas firewalls and honey pods
network security vulnerability as
assessment penetration testing and web
app threats the admission process for
this professional certificate program in
cyber security consist of three easy
steps that is interested candidates will
lead to apply by submitting the
application from online then candidates
will be shortlisted by admission panel
then selected candidates will be awarded
an offer of admission that they can
accept by paying the program fee now
coming to the last course which is
Caltech cyber security boot camp the
celtech cyber security boot camp offers
a comprehens I learning experience to
master defensive and offensive cyber
security digital forensics penetration
testing infrastructure design and more
this course equips you with practical
expertise using in demand cyber security
tools through Hands-On labs and guided
practices with a focus on Real World
skills the program covers network
security vulnerability assessment risk
management threat analysis business
continuity data privacy and security and
other things like digital fr and
Incident Management by enrolling you can
earn a prestigious celtech ctme boot
camp certificate and add up to 26 CEOs
along with Caltech ctma Circle
membership this program's online
convocation led by program director adds
to the experience Additionally you will
Master the utilization of various
Cutting Edge tools equipping you for a
successful journey in the field of cyber
security so this was calch cyber
security boot camp so we have discussed
five best courses for ethical hacking
the link of these courses you'll get in
the description you can choose as per
your choice thank you for joining us
today on this exciting Journey Through
the world of ethical hacking remember
knowledge is your super power and with
the right training you can become a
guardian of the digital world should you
need any assistance PPD project code and
other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead head in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading un
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here